my
it going ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the tim cast irl podcast
thanks for joining us smash that like
button and subscribe we got some crazy
stories for you today
outside the autonomous zone of george
floyd memorial you see in minneapolis
where the chavin trial is now taking
place
far leftist has set up an autonomous
zone and apparently someone was already
shot and killed there
that where we are entering it's it's
like a a rerun
of exactly where we were when they
defund the police
it emboldens these groups when these
people go in riot and they don't do
anything about it
it emboldens these groups and now
there's a video going around of a local
journalist who's
outside of this new autonomous zone in
minneapolis explaining what's happening
when two people dressed all in black
threatened this man
and they tell him he better leave or
else and he's shocked
i'm not i've seen it before and we'll
see it again you can expect at least in
my opinion there to be mass riots in
minneapolis no matter what
happens in this trial it's going to get
bad it's going to get intense and we're
going to talk about it
and we'll talk about a bunch of other
things too we have from christopher
ruffo apparently someone leaked him
documents
that one school's teaching kids to
worship aztec gods
and ritual sacrifice and other just i
don't know exactly what they're talking
about
but it's just very very strange the
general idea is it's anti-whiteness so
anything coming from europe is
considered
wrong or taboo it must be rejected and
this is what we're getting in our
schools now
other than that we have game stop stunks
breaking was it like 350 today or some
ridiculously high number and it's just
it's a it's a roller coaster of absolute
insanity so again thank you all so much
for hanging out my name is tim poole and
we're hanging out with conservative
activist
scott pressler you want to introduce
yourself explain what you do
thank you conservative activist that
travels the country
picking up trash registering voters and
now is on a mission to repeal
and replace those elected politicians
who are
not america first america last yes who
are america last
year so basically the people who all
this foreign aid they're giving our
money away when we're at our our worst
or our most uh desperate times basically
yeah giving money to honduras
instead of funding are homeless
democrats and republicans right exactly
and are i'm coming for you peacefully
and democratically
right on all right we'll talk about this
thanks for hanging out scott we got ian
man thanks tim hey everybody what's up
ian crossland good to see you in
crossland.net scott great to see you
again man that's right that's long hairs
we're sticking together yeah for real i
saw i ran into you at the uh dc not the
march on the sixth but before
we i saw you uh briefly at that that was
really cool to run and do that
that was like in december yeah that's
right the fight goes on
your hair's looking great man thank you
it's inspiring so you've been clipping
the ends and that's why it keeps growing
long i don't i haven't been doing that
so it hasn't uh there you go
that's strange to me i don't think that
makes sense almost counterproductive
yeah
no that seems weird all right she's
pressing all the buttons i have some of
the shortest hair on the show
i'm feeling a little shown up by these
guys with these luscious locks but i'll
survive
i don't have any hair i mean yeah
let's jump right into this before we do
ladies and gentlemen did you smash that
like button yet
also go to timcast.com and become a
member because we got a ton of exclusive
members only segments the other day we
were talking with cassandra fairbanks
about disney banning classic movies for
kids
and what this means for us culturally
it's scary stuff because i think look we
we as an older people may have seen
these things and understand these
cultural references
but they're they're going after kids and
they're taking away things like statues
and
art so these kids can't understand it
you don't gotta like the art you
understand the art
we look at old pieces of art we say
here's why it was made
here's what we think about it today but
they're erasing it out right so go to
tipcast.com become a member because it
helps support the show
and in the event in the event we get
purged or deleted or banned or whatever
you know that's where you'll be able to
find us but uh my friends i also have
another announcement
you see we have this meme on the show
that started because of alex jones and
it's i am a gorilla
it doesn't really mean much other than
like you watch the show and alex jones
said it we thought it was funny
a bunch of people then started making
gorilla emojis in the chat
and interestingly around the same time
as all this is happening we make our
famous i am a gorilla t-shirt
we get the gamestop rebellion where
they have this meme where they say
gorillas together strong so i decided to
commemorate gamestop stocks
skyrocketing back up from like it was
like four something it goes down outside
back at 350.
ladies and gentlemen go to timcast.com
click shop and you can get your very own
diamond hands gorilla t-shirt so it's
basically the same thing as i am a
gorilla but he's wearing a suit
holding wads of cash with sunglasses on
and smoking and
i just thought it was funny because i
saw what people were saying with the
gamestop thing so uh
if you'll like it and you want to get a
new edition of the iamagrilla shirt
for some reason the only shirts we're
able to make are iterations of i am a
gorilla and maybe we'll think of
something more clever in the meantime
but uh
go to teamcast.com click shop don't
forget to smash the like button let's
read this first story
we got some fox 40 check this out they
say outside the autonomous zone of the
george floyd memorial
where police aren't allowed they say
minneapolis leaders say they'll reopen a
barricaded intersection known as the
as george floyd square after the murder
trial the former police officer accused
of killing him
but the activists who serve as
unofficial leaders and organizers of the
area have issued 24 demands
before they'll step aside even calling
for the recall
of the county prosecutor why they
arrested and charged the guy
see no matter what happens it's not
enough i'll i i'd be willing to bet
they're basically saying we want first
degree murder and death penalty for for
chauvin
they want to say the square sprang up
organically in the days after floyd's
death
as people gathered to express their
grief and anger including leaving
offerings
community members set up barricades of
refrigerators trash cans and wooden
pallets to block traffic
the city eventually replaced those with
concrete barriers
the memorial now called an autonomous
zone was set up by protesters and
supporters
at the now vacant speedway station it's
very tense near the memorial
and a militant style group has closed
off several blocks with barricades
they don't allow the police inside quote
the situation at the memorial from what
i understand it's kind of volatile
said kim griffin a minneapolis resident
people that want to go and support
doesn't feel a sense of inclusion there
there is
more of like militant type atmosphere
over
and a sense of fear griffin supports
police reform
and protested floyd's death outside the
courthouse uh tuesday
but she doesn't agree with what's
happening at the memorial her nephew who
identified
to news nation as i'm as wright was shot
and
killed at the memorial over the weekend
quote police were not allowed to get
into that area
he was carried out outside of the zone
of george floyd square
it was made clear law enforcement was
not welcome to penetrate that zone
which is an atrocity because his life
was taken and i mean who knows whether
or not
he would have survived had things been
different ladies and gentlemen
here we go again it's just like what
happened last time
you guys were following what happened in
seattle and and chas
now we got a dead kid you know i i kind
of i support the right of americans to
create these zones
i mean it's kind of america is barring
police from coming into a neighborhood
the us is an autonomous zone we barred
the british from entering our houses you
know it
we kind of formed like this but this is
i don't know if you can
do it you got residents who live in
these areas in seattle when they set up
the
the capitol hill autonomous zone they
surrounded businesses and people who did
not want them there
what about their rights well we had
british citizens being surrounded by the
american revolutionaries i don't know
what life was like for them they didn't
get written in history books i'm just
playing devil's advocate too but i do
think it's important
it's our right to rise up and form
militias and say this is our
place it is kind of written into our
constitution but peacefully
peacefully peacefully assembling people
getting killed that's the completely
other problem man that's that's
something's going wrong
yeah i don't know interestingly i mean
the american revolution was it was
anything but peaceful right it was you
know a couple days
written in wasn't all the citizens that
were accidentally killed like they
didn't write that into the history books
they probably wrote some of it but
there's probably a whole lot of history
that we do not get
just in general from from anything you
know well here we go man
uh i i'm willing to bet this is it's
going to get bad i mean the city seems
to be supporting they're putting up
concrete barricades
when when the shaving trial comes to an
end you think they're going to be like
okay now that the murder trials overall
going to go away no
no no well and it's a
two-sided coin because i i understand
your point of view
and that people have the right to set up
their
own autonomous zone but on private
property
you know not where there's public access
to streets to vehicles
to uh what if an ambulance can't get
through what if you know the police
can't get in so i understand
that but at the same time i'm kind of
like wait a second look at the failed
liberal policies of california for
example or
washington or oregon it's almost like
why don't we
let these failed policies be on full
display
so people can see that it doesn't work
and why everybody's fleeing from new
york to florida why everybody is fleeing
from california
and you know do we just let things
happen and let things get
so bad that people finally wake up
yeah i don't like the idea i've heard it
before there was some republican who
said
i can't remember who this was maybe you
guys might remember where he was like
maybe we need
you know some terror attacks so that
people remember why they need our
security i don't agree with that
right right right i can't remember who
that was so i look at these autonomous
zones and my first thing is
look when it came to the revolutionary
war the regulars weren't americans
they were british regulars being
deployed to stop the the uprising from
americans who believed in
self-governance
so it would be one thing if the police
of minneapolis were protecting a
community
and then national guard came in and
tried removing the police
and people started you know rising up
and revolting it's another thing when
the community itself
you have a woman who lives here saying
we don't want this it's an atrocity
that's different now i get it there were
loyalists in the colonies
but the people who were in the colonies
fighting against the regular regulars
were the americans
and that was that was the argument don't
get me wrong there were there were
loyalists that we had you know famously
benedict arnold
there were a lot of people who were
americans and were like nah i'm gonna
serve the crown instead they're the
right call and
that was not the right call the
difference here i suppose is
i guess you know they'll they'll try and
claim the boston tea party was a riot
ignoring the fact that the only thing
that was damaged you know outside of the
the t was a lock that got replaced the
next day i guess that's like the famous
line
you know and then what we actually have
is extremists
authoritarians so perhaps
our tolerance for certain activities and
certain tactics
for a lot of people just has more to do
with our ideologies
if you're fighting to free people and
respect their property and their rights
and their safety and security
then i think you're probably doing the
right thing if you're fighting to
take over their space you kill their
children
and then tell them to shut up or else
look at they're threatening a journalist
there's a journalist who walked up and
they threatened him like they're not
fighting for freedom they're fighting
for power and control if they had like a
constitution
like a digital rights bill that they
were like we want digital rights for
every human we want
to amend the constitution with these and
they had like a list of demands that's
another story
but an armed group taking over a piece
of property and shooting
someone and threatening is like i don't
know but if
if we were in the american revolution
right now and we were objectively
talking about it we might be having the
same discussion like
well they're obviously violent
terrorists maybe they're in the right
maybe they're in the wrong
i don't know man the boston massacre
what was that the red coats were trying
to come and take guns or something is
that what happened
i can't no no i think that was something
else there was like there was a riot
happening
and it was a it was i was real i was
it's really fascinating i was reading
about the boston massacre and it was a
riot the american colonials were
riding against the regulars so the
regulars shot and killed them all
like i don't think anybody would support
if the police showed up and started
shooting and killing these people right
you know showing up and being like get
out of here because there are people
here who don't like what you're doing
violent crime is on the rise the police
have been under siege the city i'll tell
you this too
the difference here is there was
plurality support for the american
revolution
when the revolution happened there were
most people just saying i don't care
leave me alone
there were a small faction of loyalists
and there was a plurality of those who
were in favor of
independence what you have here in in
minneapolis was
a a group of extremists burned the city
down they're threatening people the
jurors
basically all of them have said they're
scared their homes will be attacked
if they if they are found out to be on
the jury
and now you have city council in
minneapolis who voted to defund the
police
and many cops leaving the department now
coming back and doing a six
six point you know whatever four million
dollar recruitment drive because the
people of minneapolis are saying
we need police the problem is they
refuse to address the extremism
these these antifa people are just going
to keep
it's just going to keep happening is
this antifa these people that have taken
are they affiliated really
you know it's it's it's black clad
leftist extremists who you know operate
in similar capacity
it's hard to know for sure how do you
guys feel about autonomous zones in
general
well i wanted to just point out the
difference here
is the ends are justifying the means
they're willing to do whatever it takes
because they feel it's for the greater
good
of whatever but the thing it's so
disingenuous
because they're fighting for this one
life
but they won't talk about all the lives
from chicago
or you know taking kovid for example you
know
they keep saying to us wear your mask or
you're gonna kill grandma
meanwhile while they're shutting down
our businesses and our schools the
border is wide open
and they're not talking about potential
carriers of the border they're not
talking about these potentially
untested people they actually released
i think 108 uh migrants who tested
positive for cova they illegally entered
the country and they got released in
texas thank you
so it's just it's disingenuous it's not
authentic it's not sincere
and we need to keep exposing
that clearly they're doing this
politically it's politically motivated
and ultimately what people need to
understand are politicians
and people across the board is if you
give in to this behavior
where you go along with a minority crowd
that is going to be potentially violent
if they don't get their will
then you are adding to the situation
and you're letting people know that if
they ever want
to get something accomplished all they
have to do is intimidate or use
fear of force or terrorism in order to
get
their needs and when you say minority
crowd you just meet a small number of
people
yes that's like anti-fun yeah not like a
racial racial minority
thank you for saying that by minority
crowd i want to clarify
by a minority of people who do not speak
for the silent
majority no this has nothing to do with
race creed color
religion anything like that thank you
for clarifying could you imagine if
these people decided to riot because
andrew cuomo killed 15 000 people
and then is now being accused of trying
to cover up the numbers
even even having one assemblyman say it
was straight up a coordinated criminal
conspiracy
imagine if when a government a governor
of a state
orders people into nursing homes killing
15 000 people
there was a protest if only there was a
single
protest if there was one person that
would speak up against the governor of
michigan for instance
have you been working up there against
whitmer i will be traveling to
pennsylvania michigan wisconsin and new
york
and as we know in several of these
states commonwealth of pennsylvania
uh michigan new york we know
that coveted positive patients were put
into nursing facilities and people
died because of those democrat policies
they're actually saying now whitner
whitmer could face criminal
charges yeah i don't think i don't think
it'll happen uh we also have cuomo's
under
federal investigation but i really just
think it's it's meant to placate the
people who are paying attention
my bigger concern is you know it really
does come down to the media i suppose
we focus on what they tell us to focus
on and there are things they don't talk
about and things they do
and they make this big story we all saw
the video of george floyd we were all
upset by it
but what about i don't know 15 000
people being killed in nursing homes
it was what was it march 24th that cuomo
started killing these people
if we had real journalists who were
doing their jobs who spoke with the
nursing homes and investigated what
cuomo was doing
instead of just calling themselves
homosexuals
you know and praising him yeah no joke
they were saying that on tv if they
actually investigated him
when by the time george floyd died
andrew cuomo was already killing nursing
home patients
where was that widespread nationwide
revolt riot over these people who lost
their lives
well and to make it even worse we
all reject when there's not consent
and when sexual advances are made that
we're not consented to
but have you noticed that the media and
talking about cuomo
they're not talking about the deaths of
the
uh elderly patients they're talking
about
these women that have come out against
him have you noticed that it's all about
the me too movement
has nothing to do with kovid and i think
that's being done very strategically by
the media
interestingly there are more stories
about coven in the nursing homes
but the biggest stories and the
headlines that go viral are the me too
ones
so i saw this from a journalist they
were like stop saying that we're not
covering
you know uh cuomo's nursing home scandal
because it was like two to one
and i'm like the problem is you'll write
50 words to 200 words
and say andrew cuomo's under
investigation for this that and this end
of story and then the me too thing
it's like this big 3 000 long form the
reckoning of me too
were we wrong about cuomo and because
they know that's what's going to make
them the money
so to a certain degree it is our fault i
mean humans love the drama
and they love the interpersonal drama of
cuomo and these women and who said he
said she said
and there's no the you know you can see
the victims right
you can see the women who are like here
i am and here's what i have to say and
it's easier for them to monetize
it's easier for them to make long-form
content what are we gonna do show videos
of the the freezer trucks full of you
know in new york they brought in those
freezer trucks man
so the in in in new york a large portion
of those that died a decent percentage
was these nursing homes
no riot i don't want riot snap in mind
you i'm just saying you can clearly see
the priorities of these people
they don't care about uh you know and
george floyd with this autonomous zone
it's not about george floyd
it's about hey we can take power it's an
opportunity to go in and do this
and rally people who normally don't care
to fight with us i want to point out too
when it comes to george floyd the media
coverage like there were two videos that
came out about george floyd the first
one
eight minutes nine minutes of the dude
with his knee on his neck
i don't think it was the full nine
minutes of him right i saw like a three
minute version
and they were like it happened for nine
minutes that was the emotional spark
that's one that burned everyone's memory
then another longer video came out of
george like
tripping out in his car being like i
can't breathe i can't breathe when
they're just talking to him
and struggling in the car get me out of
the car put me on the ground they're
like okay so they put him on the ground
and he was freaking out just this huge
built muscular guy apparently on
fentanyl uh and other
methamphetamine fentanyl methamphetamine
caffeine
caffeine and there was one other tobacco
tobacco in his system like he was just
fully pumped and um so that didn't get
much attention
i tried to share it with people and no
one really seemed to care
you're a bigot they had already seen
what they wanted to see and and man if
you have that in perspective
it's a it's a completely different story
if you know that he had fentanyl in this
system
it's a completely different story and
the medical examiner said
no signs of physical trauma there was a
combination of these factors
so again you know we talk a lot about
this because it's like one of the
biggest stories happening in the country
right now
but it just goes to show the media
there's a group of people
i think on the left corporate liberal
establishment tribalist types
they're going to go along with what the
narrative is you know if cuomo's bad
cuomo's bad why is he bad me too all
right works for me nursing homes
whatever
i don't think they want to go for the
nursing homes because they know it's
going to impact all these other democrat
governors who did similar
things then you have the the the
political
left elite who know they can easily
control and manipulate these people
so you end up with autonomous zones you
end up with you know
orange man is bad trump is bad and
here's why and it's exaggerations
manipulations and lies
it's because too many people will just
say tell me what to say and i'll say it
i'm not a big fan of the me too push i
mentioned this before it's kind of like
using poison to kill a deer
like it you can do it and it's very
effective it will kill the deer but it
taints the meat and then you can't eat
the meat so like
using me too to take a governor out is
very effective it's very emotional easy
to do
but it's not a clean kill first of all
it's not just
and it's going to be impetus to use that
again and again and again and again on
other people for putting their hand on
someone's back
like it's not a good precedent it's the
ends justifying the means that's what
scott was saying
and the problem i always talk to speak
out against this because there is no end
there's no point where we like we all
come together and say that's it we've
won
life we're done you don't accomplish
your goals of a communist utopia
and then it just stops and then one day
everyone's holding hands another under
the rainbow
no now you have to defend the revolution
now you have to set up more autonomous
zones
now you got to send out more of your
revolutionary guards to other parts of
the city where people oppose you
and seize control there they think they
can lie cheat and steal
and manipulate to gain power and that
means once they're in power
they will lie cheat and steal to
maintain that power
it all and it starts with with little
things like this
we'll see where this ends up but it's
it's amazing to me i mean
have there been were there autonomous
zones before this was this like one of
the first or what
the seattle one i don't know much about
the history of him do you have any ideas
about it
i mean i guess the stems all the way
back to occupy
wall street yeah yeah right so but it's
always been
the liberal left who has been doing the
autonomous zones
and i mean quite frankly look why don't
we have
our own autonomous zones on the right
and let's show them how it's done
[Laughter]
i'm serious clean bake sales lemonade
stands
freedom liberty fun where we have uh
our policing making sure that there's
fewer crimes not
more you know where we actually believe
uh that a social worker
uh probably can't do some of those
things that are our police are
doing yeah but listen we can't just
point at a problem and say this is wrong
that's the problem i have
with the republican party is we're
always pointing out problems but never
offering solutions the best way to show
the failure of the left
is to have a successful right and i want
to
you you actually are like embodying this
you started a trash
cleanup campaign can you explain that in
case you didn't see the show you were on
last time
well it got started in 2019 president
trump
brought attention to the city of
baltimore and i always say he did it
ungracefully
and i was just disappointed because
everybody was quick to
point the finger and to bring about
blame and judgment but nobody was
actually doing anything
and i just tweeted out to my followers
and said i'm going to baltimore
and it just started this nation-wide
campaign literally where i had people
from across the country that said scott
i want to help
and we had 200 volunteers on a monday
picked up 12 tons of trash in 12 hours
in the most dangerous streets in america
west baltimore
where the sites of the freddie gray
protests actually happened
in these streets and i met the aunt of
freddie gray who was there with us
at the cleanup and i just said wait a
second
i'm a private citizen without the
backing of the government
without any donors without any funders
and if i'm able to gather volunteers to
pick up 12 tons of trash in 12 hours
what the heck is our government doing
and why aren't they using
our resources to get it done well well i
mean
first of all someone needs to fund
the blowing up of children overseas
right so so our congress is hard at work
on this very important issue of
not actually having a say in whether or
not biden bombs syria because he didn't
have congressional approval for it but
anyway
uh it's performative they're they're
they're signing bills that give funding
to
mismanaged blue states that aren't
solving these problems they're giving
money to
foreign countries money that belongs to
the american taxpayer
it's a great point if they were if they
were allocating funds to support private
citizens to do initiatives like this
that's like the new government that's
kind of an evolution of what we need
there are things like that there are
grants the issue i take is like a 1.9
trillion dollar stimulus
and basically all of the horrible
mismanagement during covid
is swept under the rug you notice that
all the bad press for cuomo was like
bottlenecked until after the election in
austin it just burst
the pressure was building up and you
look at hunter biden
stories up under the rug cuomo nobody
questioned it
after the election okay now we have no
choice but to admit all this really bad
stuff was happening
they didn't want to risk donald trump
winning by telling people the truth
about what was really going on
now because of that mismanagement
because they because the media didn't do
their jobs in calling out cuomo
he horribly mismanaged the state
resulting in all this death
and debt so what do we get sign off that
trillion dollar
two trillion dollar stimulus dump that
money on these states that failed and
help him help bail him out
it's kind of like the freddie what is it
fannie mae freddie mac
bail out of 2008. bailing out the broken
corrupt states where democrat governors
murdered people how much did we spend
on that fannie mae freddie mac bailout
do you remember that obama signed 2008
no this spiraled the housing crisis i
mean something like trillions it wasn't
more than well
trillion was it it was about what we're
doing now again
like are we going to see that depression
again i think we're maybe
i'm not an economist i don't know but i
have seen global global food prices are
on the rise
so bloomberg reported this around the
world food is starting to skyrocket i
already talked about it like last week
because i have friends who are like
they go to the grocery store and they're
surprised to find things like 60
more for the same amount of food the
bills are way higher i don't know if you
guys have noticed this
i noticed a little bit now you actually
have the news reports from bloomberg
food is going up
it's because these states not just blue
ones many red ones but
mostly the blue ones horribly mismanaged
everything
the economy was sent into it into a
free-for-all the lockdowns made little
sense
it was 15 days we're on the one year
anniversary of 15 days slow spread how
about how about that
the economy gets decimated now they are
printing money in a desperate bid to
bail themselves out
it is obvious what what happened it was
an opportunity
to stop donald trump and to throw
everything they could at him
sacrificing everything and watching the
country burn to the ground
because it meant no more trump and they
couldn't handle it
2019 was the greatest economy we've had
in our gen of this generation or
or any of the past living generations
that's according to jim kramer whether
you like the guy or not
the greatest numbers of our lives think
i wonder if people see this now because
you know what i've heard a lot
a lot of people come to me and they're
like my paycheck is smaller
and i'm like okay ask biden i don't know
tell you man
like there you go what did you expect
was going to happen so many people
thought oh you know i'll vote for biden
and things are gonna get better no
stimulus checks well now you're gonna
get your fourteen hundred dollars not
two thousand
a lot of the things he promised just
won't come to fruition from any of these
progressives
the funny thing is i see this meme where
somebody tweeted you know conservatives
are are saying why are you
you know complaining about joe biden you
voted for him and they're like it's not
a cult and we're going to hold him
accountable and all this stuff and it's
like no no
you don't understand the point the point
is we were all screaming in your faces
he was lying to you and wasn't going to
give you anything
and trump was probably the only person
who legitimately wanted people to get
two thousand dollar checks
it was his idea he was the one that said
it to cortez was like just give him two
thousand
yeah but it was like ha ha ha and then
it's a week went by and they're like
yeah so
trump was the one who said 2000 at that
number yeah i mean as far i remember
that coming up on the show
a couple of times yeah it was kind of
his idea wasn't it but like that number
two
his response to cortez yeah i thought it
was yeah it was a 16 maybe he said 1600
i don't remember it was a lot yeah but
he was like
no give him four times more than what
you're saying right now trump was saying
2000.
and when i was in georgia knocking on
doors
for free went down three times for
lefleur and purdue
the big thing that they even had these
cars with billboards on them that were
electronic
and it said vote for democrats to get
your two thousand dollar check
and i want to make this clear to the
viewers that are watching
democrats are in full control of the
government
they have the white house they have the
senate and they have the house
congratulations democrats and like tim
said
no two thousand dollar check and the
democrats sold you out you're not
getting your 15 dollar wage
increase that you thought you were gonna
get hold on they didn't completely get
sold out
they they did bomb syria okay so they're
back to normal
i you know i don't know who wanted that
to happen but hey you know
it's uh and i'm not i'm not laughing at
that i'm laughing at the
hypocrisy that the people
were suckered in for voting for
democrats thinking
that they were actually going to get a
change
and no i just want to make it clear the
democrats are not going to give you what
you wanted
right and they're going to sell you out
for power and ultimately
joe biden listen he's been in office for
decades what were you expecting
yeah it's but you know a lot of these
young people didn't know you know when
we've had some of these leftists on the
show and they're like 24 years old
it's like oh they were you know how old
were they 10 years ago when obama got
elected they were
teenagers 12 years old or whatever now
you know it
so it's it's 2016 they were like a late
teenager in high school having no idea
what politics
was or what was going on when you call
biden a plagiarist most people probably
don't understand
like he actually dropped out of the
presidential race was the 1988 i think
because of this and he was a pleasure
wasn't it didn't boris johnson just call
him a plagiarist like a couple weeks ago
he was like build back better why did i
hear that before huh yeah
and like joe biden was accused of taking
it a lot of people thought it was a
conspiracy
like why is joe biden using the same
thing as the as the europeans who say
build back better it's like dude it's
not a conspiracy it's because joe biden
is a plagiarist he has no he doesn't
have original ideas
no i mean it's obvious he's lame yeah
2008 when he was running against
literally
he was lame as a candidate i don't know
never
thought he would ever be in the
government i was just like what a joke
and then obama made him his freaking vp
what
gave him all that power listen listen
they were saying
that the american people wouldn't want
to vote for the first black
president and so they needed an old
white man to
give them familiarity that's that's what
i heard a lot in the press back then
so that's what that was the plan you
know joe biden establishment
senator career politician old white dude
and that will help people
and then i guess the idea from mccain
was let's be progressive and and get a
woman and they check they picked
uh sarah palin i mean politics is very
often a
joke to be completely honest do you
think but real quick you know
the republicans they i think they block
the 2000
on purpose because they they want to
trump out too
that you know mcconnell and lindsey
graham and these establishment
you know party leaders were like now's
our chance no one gets any money
and the democrats need only say okay
we'll do it well here's what i think
happened
and it's unfortunate but i believe
the republican establishment took a
wager and they
thought let's say president trump
were to get reelected in the 2020
election
then that would mean that the senate
would probably
flip democrat in 2022 and
they thought it better to lose the
presidency
but maintain their control of the senate
because that would mean judges that
would mean supreme court justices and i
think they took that wager and the
establishment
stabbed the president in the back in
order to maintain power and status quo
yeah and the republican party probably
thought
we'll win in georgia and so we'll be
fine
and then we'll use biden as president as
justification for why people should vote
for us
and the democrats got everything well
and meanwhile i have to say this
500 000 republicans stayed home the
democrats
did not win georgia for any other reason
then republicans
failed to show up in the numbers that
they should have and that means that
would behoove us
to choose better candidates and so you
at home
get involved in the primary process
to choose your candidate that's going on
to the general election
otherwise you're going to get stuck with
more bad candidates
i could be flipping the numbers but what
didn't trump get like 3.2 million in
georgia
in the i can't say off the top of my
head it was like it was like that and
then i think it was like 2.7 for loffler
and purdue or whatever like it was half
a million half a million down
so my numbers may be wrong because i
vaguely remember an article but the
general idea was without trump
they can't win and they seem to think
they're going to without him
it's it's the trump party in 2024 and
you know i think
there's a there's a good chance we'll
see republicans win in 2022.
i'm not 100 convinced though i think
democrats have a good chance of just
maintaining control
now that they have basically everything
they can do a lot of things
they're not gonna i don't believe
they'll get hr one through it did pass
the house for obvious reasons but now
they need a 60
60 um you know 60 votes in the senate
republicans are not going to go for this
hr 1 is crazy
but maybe with some reforms ultimately i
just don't trust
uh the democratic party be completely
honest i don't trust the republican
party to actually do anything if they do
win
unless there are new candidates like you
mentioned through the primary process
so like i'll just throw it to you guys
right now can can you actually scott you
know you're working on this
can you can you name one person from
each party that you think is
actually trying to do good i would say
on the right i think ted cruz and josh
hawley
are trying to do good i would put stock
in them
as good candidates
on the right side on the left
let's say all of congress too even the
house not just senators i love matt
gates
yeah give me some gates and in fact i
i wanted him to run against marco rubio
and primary him but he's not going to do
that in florida unfortunately
um desantis look i judge a person
republicans
not their talk but their walk if you are
results driven if you are actually
focused on accomplishments if you are
actually writing
bills and passing legislation and
preventing unconstitutional measures
like the mask mandates
uh desantis would be my boy and
uh he's he's doing great he's doing
great you think he'll be vp with trump
2020 you know i want him to stay as
governor
desantis you're doing a great job stay
as governor please we need you to stay
in there and you know he's young he's
young and he's got
young kids and he's a wonderful wife i
could see him being definitely a
presidential contender for the future
but wait can you name
at least one democrat you think is
trying to do good
that's a hard question no well it's hard
because you know
um i mean look at look at kristen cinema
for example i know the progressives
they're really angry with her because
she
she was this was this progressive
fighter that was fighting for 15.
and look what she voted against the
other day she was one of the eight
democratic senators that voted against
the fight for 15.
so i don't really want to primary her
i'm not i'm not a fan of of
the 15 minimum wage oh i'm not either i
think there are other ways we have to
solve this problem i i will say this i
certainly want people to make more than
fifty dollars yes
and i think there's a lot of issues
around minimum wage
no i don't i wouldn't uh personally i'm
not a fan of cinema because
she was fighting for 15 and then as soon
as she got the power she said later
i'm i'm like how many politicians we
have are honestly saying here's what i
want to do and i'll do it and then they
do
it's easy to point out many republicans
it's easy you know ted cruz holly far
from perfect but i do believe like
they're fighting for what they said they
were going to fight for yes
rand paul is the easiest yes like rand
paul is probably like one of the pardon
me doctor i forgot
on the left i can give credit to roconna
um because he he called out pelosi when
she was obstructing covert relief
but it really is hard to find democrats
who are like i'm going to do this trust
me and then doing it not even aoc
she's like i'm gonna i'm gonna challenge
nancy pelosi and then vote for her every
single time
there is one gentleman i forget his name
but
he continues to primary debbie wasserman
schultz
in florida canova yes i give respect to
canova
because he seems that he's been
consistent in his messaging
and just he won't lock in step with the
democratic party just because of debbie
wasserman so i give credit to
anova we had tulsi yeah that's what i
was thinking and she
she was the real deal yeah it was like i
can't be part of this joke anymore
and basically or whatever i'm going at
it from the media now because it's
way more effective to change culture
there was a uh a joke the left was
saying they said um
until sea gabbard was was assigned
republican at birth
making a joke about her and it's like
she's such a progressive she's like in
favor of gun control
she's disagreeing with she uh she's
anti-nuclear power
like at least in her policy positions
i've criticized uh her position for that
i disagree with them
but you could clearly see that she was
at least attempting to cross the aisle
and shake hands and be like let's work
together
and she abstained i believe she
abstained from impeachment right she was
the one of the few who was like i'm not
getting involved and there were like two
other democrats that said no i think so
jeff van drew i'd shout out for the
democratic party but he quit
he joined the republicans interesting
yeah you know
lately rashida tolebs said a few things
on twitter that i
was very surprised and happy to see i'll
give her a shout out i i
supporting human rights and the right to
freedom of speech i don't know it's a
lot of media spin so it's hard to say
that like she's the real deal but i'm
i'm
really happy from what you know what i'm
going to absolutely say
i i will say rishi to tilley i disagree
with her a lot of things
but she's consistent right so she voted
against the omnibus bill
that was like a lot of this foreign
spending and bloat for reasons that you
know i probably don't agree with
and a lot of policies don't agree with
i'm just looking for someone who's going
to be like here's what i want to do and
i will do it
i look at almost every single politician
and they're like if you vote for me
i'm going to get into congress and i'm
going to end this blockade
i'm going to fight for kitchen table
issues like the economy and jobs
and then 31 democrats get in and the
first thing to do is thank you for
letting me in impeach him
impeach him i don't care about your
insurance i want to impeach trump
that's what they did that's why i'm
sorry man when
you it was 31 districts right they they
flipped from 2016 to 18.
wow you got these moderate it was more
than that i think it was like 44.
wow whoa in 2018 but it was still fewer
than the 63 that we flipped in 2010
under president obama right so they want
to make it seem like it was this
massive big landslide no the biggest was
in 2010 under president obama just yeah
well so you had these democrats
promising to fight for you
yes so so people were sitting there
watching republicans in 2016 have the
house the senate
and you know the presidency not a whole
lot got done which is amazing the
republicans have the power but they
don't want to do it because the
establishment doesn't like trump
and so then these people say give me
something different i'm sick of this
culture war stuff
and along came these moderates i'm doing
air quotes and they were like if you
vote for us
we will fight for health care and jobs
we don't care about trump we don't care
about his naughty words
we're going to try and work with the
republicans to get you something
something tangible
and then what happened right away nancy
pelosi walked right up to each and every
one who won and said now you'll do as i
say and they said yes ma'am
and so then they went all in on
impeachment there was nothing
substantive
and you know if it were me i'd say no
i understand mitch mcconnell is
obstructing the bills the house is
sending because there is a break this
happens it happens in politics
the senate will be republican the house
will be democrat and nothing gets done
but i still would not entertain this
ridiculous bs that
was this this fake impeachment for what
reason
that's what we got i don't know
vehemence it was weird it seemed like an
emotional response
from the outside it looked so ridiculous
the impeachment yeah
and then look at going back to what we
were talking about with cuomo
how like the news was being held back
the press wouldn't report it
and then only after the election did it
get released same with kovat the numbers
went down 55. they're like covenant
numbers are down 55
now that trump's out of office then it
was a week later now it's 60
and then a couple weeks ago now it's 70
down now that trump's out office they
weren't saying that now that trump's out
of office but
but but but they weren't holding that
news back that news just happened after
trump
i'm saying i'm saying you had the hunter
biden story suppressed
and then after the election oh that
whole thing was true by the way you had
the cuomo nursing home numbers
and then they suppress it and then after
the election oh by the way cuomo's
you know killed these people then you
had impeachment officer sicknick in the
capital riots
oh he was killed by a fire extinguisher
and then after impeachment
oh that wasn't true the time news
article about fortification of elections
could have come out before the election
it had been happening since 2019 they
knew about it yep
they waited until after the election
well of course of course yeah the shadow
the shadow campaign the fortification
they called it
they they you know i looked at that
article and i'm like
always returned to the scene of the
crime they wanted everybody to know i
mean that figuratively youtube calm down
they wanted everybody to know the work
they were doing to fortify the election
hard work man as i described it they
they oceans 11's trump
you know the rules were changed a year
in advance mail-in voting all of these
big drives
there was one woman in texas who got
arrested for for ballot harvesting but
you had you know
votes in the park or whatever wisconsin
a lot of things that were
they were challenged and the supreme
court just said no we don't care about
none of this we're not going to hear it
and then clarence thomas was like if
we're not going to hear it before
we're not going to hear it during and
we're not going to hear it after when
will anyone get resolution on any of
this stuff
no i guess you won't so anyway that
this whole thing started by asking scott
because you're you're going after these
america last politicians to be able to
name
somebody and it's like how why is it
that it's easy to name a handful of
conservatives that are doing what they
say they want to do republicans
and it's so difficult to find democrats
that are you know doing what they say
look i think you need only look at hr
one that wants to it's this voting bill
they call it voting
rights bill or it's actually just a
voter reform bill they want to lower the
voting age to 16.
that's that's as low information as you
can go for a political party
the democrats say we just want more
people to be able to vote and i'm like
i'd love it if everyone
you know of a certain age had the right
had the ability to vote
but i also think if you're if that's
your goal
you really want low information voters
like people who don't know what's going
on
you know what i mean yeah stupid people
are allowed to vote don't get me wrong
i'm just saying it's indicative of what
the party represents
i would have voted for whoever my
parents told me to vote for if i was 16.
right
right yes you probably i think if you
want more voters you should make it so
that felons can vote
because i do think that's a right and i
think that once you've paid your debt to
society by going to prison
if you want voters get the felon vote i
agree
i i think that people who serve their
their time and debt to society should
have their
they shouldn't lose rights for this
right they should it's like state by
state
here's your gun and here's your vote
have a nice day exactly yeah nah but we
and
it's really crazy you get a felony like
you're you're a second-class citizen at
this point
that's too bad and i i think that's
wrong i do i think we're supposed to
have
rehabilitation not retribution people
who go to prison
we're supposed to be like you promise to
do better all right okay
come on out here's your job here are
your rights
you can participate same as everybody
else if you do it again you go back to
prison if it's already illegal why do we
need to do these things
i'm not a fan of certain like
non-violent felonies for sure like if
it's like
repeating violent felonies maybe maybe
you got to remove them from society for
a while but
violence right you you get you know
maximum security prisons and things like
that
but uh yeah especially non-violent stuff
which is another
i'll say it's a disappointment i was
hoping that trump on the way out would
take bolder action
in terms of pardoning people and he
didn't and he pardoned that that you
know corrupt was it the mayor from
detroit or whatever so
what was your thoughts on trump
generally
well i mean today i put out a tweet
talking about policies that
i stand for you know i want
fair trade not free trade and
i want lower corporate tax and i want to
secure the border and you know a lot of
the things that i was tweeting about
uh people were like well those are
president trump's policies
and it was just interesting to see how
every single one of those
that he was working towards or had
accomplished
and uh and that's what i think the
future of the republican party is
and endless wars he put a cap
on insulin prices what's the first thing
that president uh biden does he removes
the cap
now insulin is skyrocketing during a
pandemic i mean how heartless can you be
to our community facing diabetes
that you're going to skyrocket the price
of insulin
and uh it was just really interesting
that the things that i put out were
so non-controversial like for example
let's stop giving funding and foreign
aid
to countries that say death to america
or hate us or who are having
camps for terrorism bomb
training classes you know why are we
funding
those countries can anyone answer me
that question
and why are we not focusing on building
our infrastructure making sure that our
schools
are funded and not worse than japan why
are we
rebuilding china why are we rebuilding
the rest of the world not investing in
our infrastructure
and i think if we move forward with
those policies we'll have a very
successful
right what um you said fair trade which
sounded kind of interesting how would
you define that
for example oh i know i love talking
about this issue i am not a
free trader i think free trade is
fool's trade for example why am i
going to allow another country like
china to impose a
tariff on my products while
i don't impose a tariff back on them i
just think that's
the most asinine thing ever that i'm
going to allow you to steal from me
and basically i'm going to reward you
for stealing from me
by then not imposing a tariff back on
you i just think that is
fool's trade and so if you do it to
my products i'm gonna do it back to you
and i just think it was so also asinine
that for the longest time america had a
higher corporate tax than other
countries
why not make ourselves competitive and
say wait a second if we lower the
corporate tax
maybe more businesses are going to come
to our country as opposed to leaving the
country
to go to a corporate tax haven overseas
and i just think we need to make things
more common sense
and just go wow let's go to the lowest
common denominator to make things more
competitive to bring more business to
america
combine those issues right joe biden was
in favor of free trade agreements
he was in favor of increasing the
minimum wage and increasing corporate
tax rates
what will those three things do okay if
i can set up a factory in china and i'd
pay a
small a lower tax and a lower wage to my
employees i save a bunch of money
and then i can send all my products back
to the us for free
is an extraction it is it is it is the
most insane combination of pockets and
the american workers will be too
expensive
to hire because they're all making a
gigantic wage
at minimum so you gotta hire outside the
country it'll drive american salaries
and wages down
it'll force them down and we see this
happen okay these free trade agreements
did this
why it's why bernie sanders in 2016 was
popular and trump because bernie was
saying the same things
open borders was a koch brothers
proposal these free trade agreements
right and he got smeared the world
socialist website called bernie sanders
a capitalist nationalist free trade is
dangerous they called him that it was
hilarious free trade doesn't lead to
freedom it leads to corporate slavery
like if you allow corporations to trade
unfetteredly they do things like the
what was it the um trans-pacific
partnership
where they're basically giving
corporations the ability to sue
american citizens to sue our government
for like
defamation or for what they would call
like uh it was an extraction
it was like hollowing out the united
states the american workers were getting
left behind
small small towns were falling apart and
that's why people
just were screaming i met us helen i
can't take it anymore
and then bernie you know it's
unfortunate that bernie sold out
and he went totally establishment and
changed his tune
from fighting for the working class to
you know white privilege
and social justice because that i guess
he became rich and he didn't want to let
it go yeah
oh there was the in the trans-pacific
partnership there was a clause called
the uh
investor state dispute settlement that
said that if uh american citizens were
to discriminate is the actual word they
use and say i don't want to buy
malaysian oil
that the then the malaysian oil
companies could sue the government for
discrimination against them
and then we as taxpayers would have to
pay this corporation's
lawsuit i think i think one of the
reasons we saw the economy do so well in
2019
was a combination of trump's policies he
was you know we saw in michigan
the auto factory started coming back
because
well now the famous line from michael
moore
michael moore said trump walks into this
into this executive executive
office or whatever with these these big
wigs and says i will put a 30
tariff on your vehicles if you make them
overseas and no one will ever buy your
car again
and michael moore was like no one ever
said that to these people
to these to these these fat cats who are
sending the jobs overseas for dirt wages
for
you got to think about what these
companies do they don't want to pay
health care benefits
they don't want to pay a living wage so
what happens you give them a good free
trade agreement
and they can hire some people in china
for pennies on the dollar with no
rights and then sell that car back to
the american people but guess what
the american people are slowly losing
their access and wealth
so the the resources of the americans
are being stripped away the only thing
that really props all of this up
and this is where it gets more dastardly
before i start i'll say
scott your response like your your your
the things you talk about is a sound
responsible american policy of americans
working hard and earning what they
you know what they work for right now
it's the petro dollar
it's it's joe biden basically being like
it doesn't matter how much money we
print because we'll shoot anybody who
tries to trade oil off the dollar
so we can print all the money in the
world and we don't got to export
anything other than
killing people going to other countries
blowing them up you combine donald
trump's policies
and then you look at why the
establishment hated him so much
abraham accords historic peace
agreements in the middle east
yet there was there was an increase in
drone bombings he did get rid of isis
though
so trump was not perfect in the middle
east but we weren't seeing the
escalation in syria
we were seeing de-escalation across the
board and these peace agreements meant
we are less likely to go and blow up
people who defy the petrodollar
and trump was like americans can work
hard and earn their living
and then you have the the establishment
elites going
we have to work oh no no i'd rather just
shoot people
military industrial complexes like but
who we sell our bombs to
so all of these status quo establishment
people were just like
dude it was so easy to extract wealth
and then the military industrial complex
was like it was so easy just selling
bombs
can we just go back to pointing the
american gun and other countries who
refuse to use the petro dollar again
then we don't gotta work well since
we're talking about oil for a second
why isn't the news talking about the
fact
that joe biden stopping the keystone
pipeline that's just
putting more money in putin's pockets
by making us less energy independent
and nobody's talking about under
president trump we went to number one
i think we were number one saudi arabia
was number two and russia was number
three
right by not having the keystone
pipeline we're making ourselves
vulnerable again
to russia uh having a bigger sphere in
geopolitics and not only that but
let's talk about for a second the the
democrats always like to say that they
are green and they care about the
environment they are these stewards
listen
the oil is coming into our country one
way
or another it's either coming by rail
it's coming by ship
it's coming by automobile right which
causes more of a carbon
footprint pipeline or any of the other
three
uh things i just mentioned and so that
shows me
they don't actually care and joe biden's
policy
uh doesn't have anything to do with the
green effect whatsoever
there's a lot to break down uh so it i
believe it
it is simply true the keystone pipeline
a pipeline transferring oil
consumes less carbon than freight
delivery correct
then there's a question about which
leaks more and i i believe and i could
be wrong so fact check me
that it still leans heavily against
freight delivery that freight is more
likely to spill or leak than the
pipeline does but the pipeline did have
many leaks
so i i gotta say you know what let me
give this one to to the left
well just for the sake of argument i'll
say okay fine the keystone pipeline you
didn't like and you shut it down because
you believe in the environment
i'm so glad that you're concerned about
renewable energies and reducing our
carbon emissions
so when do we open our new power plant
our new nuclear power plants when do we
get these thorium salt reactors online
which are zero carbon emission carbon
neutral
renewable and safe and they oppose it
even tulsi gabbard was opposed to this
and i like tulsi gabbard we have a
fusion uh
research facility at jpl the jet
propulsion laboratory in california that
looks like it's like on the horizon
where's that at
who's stopping that who who's why isn't
that in the headlines of every paper
saying every day if we want to talk
about green energy
and and i agree like i think if we want
to be number one
energy exporters energy production
fusion energy is going to change the
world
so if we if we accomplish that then oil
is a thing of the past
for now the best energy i believe the
best energy return on energy invested is
nuclear energy
for some reason they don't want you know
what i think it is
i don't think it's about energy i think
it's about
holding this this military uh um
yeah the petro dollar yeah yeah it's
it's about having control
strategically around the planet and
justifying it so long as everyone's
using oil
and and and they have to use the dollar
to exchange it and we have the weapons
and we're positioned
then that's it it's control for the
establishment uh
two things i agree with you if we went
off the petro dollar it could be the
american dollar could be completely
useless it would be wiped out yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
it'll be totally wiped out and i'll be
broke as for the pipeline
i agree it's messy it spills there's
lots i don't know 20 30 how many spills
last year it was like 26 yeah yeah
quite a bit of spills but it's like
they're saying look we have the cutter
turkey pipeline
so it doesn't the oil is going to spill
regardless of if it's coming out of
russia or if it's coming out of canada
but it's like they don't want to spill
it on the floor of the ivory tower they
don't want to mess up
our luscious land but they just want to
mess up their luscious land and they
still want to transport the
get the same dirty crap so i think it's
insane i think
i don't know i mean i'm not i don't live
on the land i know that people that live
on the land that are having a pipeline
drought
drove through their yards and getting
oil spilled into their crops and stuff
are devastated but
it's if we're gonna drill it out of the
ground anyway when i when i talk to
people about keystone
they immediately say it's not about oil
spills it's about the native americans
right to the land
and then i'm like okay well if there's
legitimate land ownership issues and
i absolutely respect like you know we go
back in time and there are a lot of
violations of treaties and things like
that
but that doesn't mean shut the pipeline
down it's already built
i mean you've got people who have spent
all these resources on it i suppose
maybe it means move it
or i don't know what your the argument
really becomes because joe biden's
reason for shutting it down
it was it was what climate change you
know so it feels like they're moving the
goal post in that regard
that when it becomes an issue of native
american sacred land it's kind of like
all right i guess but weren't we just
talking about climate change because i'm
definitely willing to have that
conversation i don't i don't want to
steal anybody's land you know what i
mean like i believe in private property
rights so if there's like legit claims
like oh you got a problem keystone if
you're building on someone else's
property
why aren't we having that argument then
why is it all about climate change and
you're ignoring it if you cared about
the native americans maybe that would be
the forefront of this conversation and
the no dapl protests were focused on
that
but they were sending in cops to go shut
it down and where are they where the
democrats
it's all just climate change is the core
issue meanwhile
the more we slow ourselves down in our
energy production it's just benefiting
china
who is building more coal power plants
i'll tell you man
if they listen my problem with the
climate change crowd
is that they want me to sacrifice they
want me to do all these things i'm
absolutely willing to do
i love trees i love nature i love being
out in the wilderness and all that stuff
we're building a little chicken city
it's great solar panels and batteries
absolutely yep solar power we try it we
try and do our best biodegradable uh
kerrig cups because we want to make sure
for sure
we're recycling it's the it's what's it
called pla it's the it's the cornstarch
version stuff
we're very very eco-friendly here not
pla that's a type of plastic
all right all right what is it then
what's the cellulose maybe i'm not sure
i thought it was i thought yeah i
thought pla was this
was it could be wrong i need a plastics
expert
it's it's it's made of it's made of
cornstarch it's like a plastic
so it breaks down and so we do these
things and then i look to
these celebrities and they're flying in
private jets they're buying beachfront
property and i'm like
so are you really concerned about this
because you'd be building nuclear power
plants if you really cared about i'm not
really concerned about the
the carbon emissions because we can
recapture it and turn it into graphene
by depositing carbon dioxide onto
palladium i mean there's tests and
studies like why isn't that also on the
like i think you got to think a little
bit
a little bit forward politics yeah
they've got a boogeyman they got the
money they need to sell the oil
and they're acting like climate change
is important but they got to sell the
oil
i think machine turning i think climate
change is a big problem and i think
these elites
their mentality is if everyone else
sacrifices i won't have to
i'm like sorry like who are you to fly
in a private jet and by beachfront
property because you think everyone else
is going to do the heavy lifting and you
don't have to
that's like imagine of a roommate and
he's just like sitting back like you
guys clean the house
i'm just gonna sit here and eat pizza
all night and do whatever i want it's
like nah we all gotta pitch in bro
you can't be the one complaining about
how the house is all messy and then be
the one who's sitting in your room
playing video games all night drinking
mountain dew and eating pizza
like everybody's got a pitch in to clean
this place up so when i hear this from
them i don't
trust them i don't believe them i don't
i'm sorry i do think climate change is a
problem
i just don't believe them when they say
they care so when keystone gets shut
down
there are so many questions around it is
it more dangerous are there more spills
there's arguments it's not true
is it more energy efficient is there
less carbon emissions from it
so maybe it was a net positive well i
don't believe the liars who are
telling me all these things and then and
then bs'ing me and who also reject
nuclear power
sorry i've not heard a good argument
against nuclear power the only argument
i ever hear is fukushima three mile
island in chernobyl
and i'm like look chernobyl early
technology
soviet union shoddy authoritarianism
like shoddy workmanship authoritarianism
essentially slave labor the whole thing
was was a failure and it collapsed and
it was really really bad chernobyl was
bad
fukushima massive earthquake massive
earthquake
flood giant flood so i understand that's
the best argument against nuclear power
it was the tsunami and then the it was
the earthquake and then the tsunami that
came in
and that the reason that's a good
example is because they built fukushima
correctly
and a natural disaster occurred causing
this damage i'll have that argument
absolutely
but we also have thorium salt reactors
and we can build them inland and away
from fault lines and other places like
this
doesn't produce corium it wouldn't have
the impact on the earth and they're both
types of nuclear power but they're
completely different chemical reactions
so
so where is it where is you know we we
have this stuff on the horizon we hear
about fourth generation nuclear power in
europe it's buried under the fear of
ignorance
people don't understand the difference
or often of thorium and
or is it a boogeyman can weaponize
nuclear sounds scary right
so they can tell other voters no no
don't let them do it vote for us and
we'll save you
and then in the meantime they actually
just it's a detriment to everybody else
when they restrict this technology
granted i think everybody's in favor of
fusion so if we get the jpl's fusion
ignition
you know to happen then it's going to be
you know then the us dollar would
collapse probably and the entire world
would have
unlimited energy and well fusion's not
unlimited
it's not it's it's just it's just great
tens of thousands of years worth
in in like a piece like it does it's not
unlimited it just goes for a long
long time energy return on energy
invested is that high
it's high like we can produce a lot of
energy with less input into it
but i don't think it's like you know
cold fusion is like the theoretical
great like we're talking about like
regular fusion they're trying to get
ignition where
you know they can make the process yeah
when the when the deuterium collides and
becomes
uh helium it releases uh like a leftover
form of matter that's extracted as heat
which then can be converted into
like a steam which could create a laser
to continue the reaction and then you're
creating more heat
than is needed to produce the laser long
scientific story short i just keep
pumping deuterium in which is in
all over the ocean you know we get a lot
of it it's politics let's just slap a
name on it
green fusion yes that's perfect
all we need is a good pr stunt that's
right green fusion
i like it yeah don't call it nuclear
yeah we should we
uh how about we don't call it nuclear
and we call it you know green decay
no decay is too negative right yeah
what's what's a word we can use instead
of nuclear energy
you know no no no so it's like green
green fusion's nice
green radiant or something green fusion
well but if we're talking about nuclear
power plants which is different from the
fusion what can we say it's also a type
of nuclear power that's the crazy thing
they're all that all this has happened
in the nucleus of atoms so it just
depends on the type of fusion the green
fusion deal
yeah who can oppose the green fusion i
don't think anyone yeah we'll call it
the green energy atomic energy
yes the green energy deal there we go
all right do you support the green
energy deal definitely oh there we go
congratulations sounds enticing tell me
about it
is that everything with race
relationships like you know there are
really good the democrats which is
something i think we could learn from
them
they're great at naming these bills you
know they'll call it the
equality act which we all know is yep
and equal and has nothing to do with
equity
and so we need to do a better job like
why would you vote
against the save the puppies and kittens
act
why would you do that don't you love the
dolphins too
save the puppies act what does that do
it provides 17 billion dollars for the
war effort to bomb things
well you see why are you calling to save
the public well
we saw a video of a dog in syria yeah
and we were concerned that the militants
there might harm it so we're going to
save the puppies
by bombing syria and taking their oil
because the dogs could get sick from the
oil
yes and the average american doesn't
understand all of the pork that goes
into it and they don't understand
the new covid bill doesn't actually a
hundred percent
go to our paychecks and to american
citizens
and then they use that as propaganda to
say oh
see the republicans won't vote for this
bill meanwhile the republicans
understand
the poison pill that went into the bill
have you read 1984 i have not it's great
it's by george orwell
about dystopian reality in the year 1984
um and he wrote it before the year so
it's like a futuristic
world war where there's these two giant
war powers basically and they're just
pure propaganda and you're always at war
or you're at peace or you're a war or
you're at war with someone else
and all you're getting is news media
they have this thing called double speak
and this is basically double speak
they'll call it the ministry
of peace and that's where they declare
war that's their war department
and that's what they're doing with these
bills it's it's
you know i don't know what a patriot act
well patriot act well look at them
seeking justice but doing it in an
unjust way burning down cities yeah
remember that's in the name of peace you
remember the cnn article that said
meet the antivir group who seeks peace
through violence no joke that was like
cnn wrote that almost speaks through
violence that's just like you know
i can't say i i i i will never i will
never run for office but i swear if i
was in congress if i was in the senate
or whatever
i'd draft a bill called the like the
donald trump is the worst president act
and it would it would just do all these
awesome things it would be like
you know the peace people the checks
they want this is so
implicit in our system in our video
games and our movies like
the heat there's a bad guy causing cast
the hero kills him
and then everyone's happy again and like
so it's in our brains like oh if you
destroy the enemy there will be peace
that's that's why wonder woman was a
great movie do you see wonder woman the
first one she's got mm-hmm
uh i'm gonna spoil it for everybody it's
fairly old at this point
but basically wonder woman believes if
she defeats the god of war
everyone will be live happily ever after
and war will end
and then you know chris pine's character
is like it doesn't work that way people
just fight sometimes
and then when she defeats ares the god
of war nothing changes
because all he was doing was whispering
in people's ears the people were
carrying on they were fighting
and so it's a cool movie because it's
ideas you think defeating this one bad
guy
solves all your problems the left the
left believes in this they're like trump
is the problem trump is the problem we
better vote for by now biden's doing the
same things
it's worse actually trump gave more
people stimulus checks
than than biden is and people are
surprised and now biden is means testing
it
so less people are getting uh people are
getting less money
and they're surprised to find that out
but you know to be fair the left still
hates trump more than this
but they genuinely believe a lot of
people thought vote out trump and then
it'll be utopia
there's this funny meme where it was
like y'all are so dumb if you think
biden's gonna bomb syria you're making
this up
and it's just like now it gets shared
over and over and over again yeah
because it's all like all the gloating
trump supporters like high-fiving each
other and laughing like told you so
and don't forget the anti-war
progressives who are laughing too saying
told you so as well
and then you have you know for what it's
for for whatever reason the
establishment shill types who are
tribalists just don't care they're like
whatever
you know well i think the work that
we're doing going into 2022 is
so critically important and here's why
you know here we're talking about the
media
that gets to write whatever it wants and
there's
no accountability none
we can't hold the media's feet to their
fire
right and we can't hold them accountable
and then we have these politicians like
cuomo
and where is the justice for his actions
and so i think the average feeling
of the american person is they feel
so discouraged because they feel like
they have no power
they can't hold anybody accountable the
people that lead them
the people that represent them and
ultimately the people that they see on
tv who
lied to them and that's why 2022 is
important because we
finally have the opportunity to do a
couple things if you're a conservative
or if you want to take over peacefully
and democratically
the republican party 2022 is your
opportunity
to use the primary democratic process to
replace these america last politicians
with america first
ones and i'm just encouraging everybody
to get involved that this is your final
moment that if you want to have
accountability in the process
then join the voting process
let's talk about the media because you
mentioned they can write whatever they
want and i'm just i'm absolutely dying
to cover this because i just it's about
me
and you know love myself uh i tweeted
impeach queen elizabeth this is clearly
not
a real real tweet but uh michael malus i
learned from the best
and i put a bunch of party hat
celebration emojis followed by the
winking meme from juan division
like can i make it any more obvious you
can't impeach the queen that was the
joke because they want to impeach trump
so basically what happened was something
happened where the queen was called
racist i guess i have no idea
i don't care about the royal family or
megan markel or whatever it is they're
doing but apparently there's something
about the baby
and then people were complaining about
the queen or something so then i
jokingly put impeach queen elizabeth
jokingly obviously in what what reality
would someone think you i legitimately
thought you could impeach
a monarch if it were that easy we
wouldn't have had a revolution
i vote to impeach king george or
whatever so
here we go ladies and gentlemen let's
talk about no accountability in media
from me from m-e-a-w-w can queen be
impeached call for monarch's removal
after megan and harry's racism claim in
oprah interview
so uh this is just absolutely incredible
let me read this paragraph for you
several people criticized the monarchy
for its ignorant response
which failed to address the actual
issues raised by sussex's
american journalist timothy daniel poole
better known as temple oh this is my
middle name
on social media even went on to call for
the impeachment
of the queen he tweeted impeach queen
elizabeth first of all she's queen
elizabeth ii
the other queen queen elizabeth is dead
i'm pretty sure that's out of context
they didn't put all the emojis
that's right they didn't put all the
party head emojis celebrating
the 35 year old who was also a youtuber
political commentator received support
from people on the social site as one
user wrote
let's call congress into session because
we're the world police right
this this this is a journalist like a
human being wrote this
and so some people have pointed out
they're not stupid
they did it on purpose they're trying to
manipulate the people who don't use
social media into genuinely believing
i'm calling
i would love for this to be out of my
wikipedia page just please tim poole has
called for the impeachment it's here
hey newsguard certified source ladies
and gentlemen wow but as if you could
call
congress into session to remove the
british queen
it's amazing stuff they write this stuff
without doing any research let me read a
little bit more they say
another user comment uh commented then
let's make it happen
before or after her next election asked
a third user
what whoa that's amazing
ladies and gentlemen please share this
segment with your friends and family
to help them understand why the media is
fake news
not all of it not all the time but just
come on so
i'm going to reveal the dark secret i'm
going to i'm going to reveal a very dark
secret my friend
um i was i wasn't gonna say anything
about this
but because i've accomplished my goal
already i think it's now fair that i can
reveal
my experiment yeah i i've been saying
for a long time i hate twitter and i
don't want to use it right
and then i thought you know i got 810
000 followers and like there are people
who follow me
what what is the upside of twitter
what's the point of using it i mean you
can generate news coverage and attention
for yourself and people are it's a
community they're talking
but for me running a business there is
zero upside it is only a detriment
tweets are taken out of context i'm
accused of things i didn't say or mean
and i'm like
i'll say something that's like you know
i think
the famous joke is i like pancakes you
hate waffles and that's what twitter is
so i decided to do an experiment i call
this anti-tweeting
i tweeted you need to understand the
power of anti-tweeting
journalists don't do research so what
you anti-tweet
is taken as law so anti-tweet stuff and
watch the news world sound like
lunatics the point being instead of
tweeting
actual opinions tweet garbled nonsense
and leftist tribalist talking points to
see what happens
so i've tweeted biden is the most
popular president in american history
i've tweeted biden rule so excited for
his speech just things that i just i
don't care i don't care about twitter
but i have a theory
my theory was news media commentary on
an individual is based off of their
tweets and nothing else
they won't do research and so i had this
idea if i
spend a certain amount of time tweeting
things that are absolutely
counter to my actual personality on this
show because i don't care about twitter
anyway
i'll tweet things like martin is great
party hat celebration i tweeted uh
uh when they announced joe biden was
gonna give a speech like i am so excited
i have been
in anxiety waiting for this speech to
happen this is going to be amazing
buy in rules and i'm like i'm just
waiting i want to see if it'll work
because i genuinely believe it will
i got the idea because i tweeted that
the mr potato head thing was stupid who
cares about the gender of potato
and the independent took my tweet and
claimed i was an outraged conservative
and i just i was what i was making fun
of the people who are making fun of me i
don't care about a potato
so i'm like okay let's play this game
i'll just tweet
garbled nonsense and left tribal talking
points like pro-democrat stuff and see
what happens
and sure enough amazing like only a week
an article pops up saying tim poole
calls for the impeachment of the queen
and i was like
it works it absolutely works so now i'm
just gonna start i'm like i don't look i
don't care if people follow me or not i
hate twitter i think it's an awful place
i'm just going to either the full-on you
know michael malus is one of the masters
of twitter
he knows how to just tweet things you
can't decipher yeah
and then it's a reflection of the tribal
individual so if you know when he says
we don't deserve donald trump that's
like the easiest
explanation because you don't know if
it's for or against trump and then
people who assume he's on the right will
say you love trump
on the left we'll be like you're right
we don't deserve this so i'm thinking
like i'll do a series of those things
very ridiculous posts like i got to be
honest i did put the winking emoji on
the impeach queen elizabeth thing
but when i typed in impeach queen
elizabeth i was sitting there thinking
for a second i'm like
is this stupid enough to work like it's
a really stupid tweet
you know what i mean like is this gonna
trick any journalist i underestimate you
whatever
i don't care about twitter click and
here we go now we have an article
tim poole calls for the impeachment of
the queen but guess what it's historical
fact now
which means on wikipedia you can add a
section says tim poole called for the
impeachment and removal of queen
elizabeth
and it's it's certified but here's the
best part
my public statements don't count as a
legitimate source a reliable source
here's the best part m-e-a-w-w
is a newsguard-certified site i don't
know what's considered reliable by
wikipedia
someone could now add to my wikipedia
tim pool called for impeaching the queen
i can then publicly state to millions of
people on my show
i was screwing with the media because i
thought it was funny and they can't
add my explanation to the wikipedia
because statements from me don't count
but a journalist
claiming i said something does i figure
if i carry on with this anti-tweet
campaign eventually get to a point where
i can easily prove the paradox
because my wikipedia page should end up
being garbled nonsensical gibberish
like tim poole a pro democrat biden
donator uh donor who regularly cheers
for donald trump on you know on
you know on youtube or whatever and it's
just like make it nonsensical
so what'll end up happening journalists
don't do research
but my public statements don't count as
a reliable source the more journalists
quote tweet me
and the more they say tim poole did x
the more
my historical record will turn into
garbled mangled nonsense
and i'm all here for it it'll be
hilarious i keep thinking about the
egyptian hieroglyphs and i wonder how
many of them were
the garbled garbled sarcasm i don't know
twitter's a new thing man yeah but
garbled sarcasm isn't
you could be like i'm a pro peace
isolationist who loves that joe biden
just bomb syria
you could say something like that that's
an anti-tweet sort of so what what
not necessarily right because if i said
it's it's so great that joe
joe biden bombed syria they'll read that
as sarcasm if i just say
it's it's it's uh a good anti-tweet
would be i'm proud to have a president
who can make decisive actions
in the middle east this is real
leadership right
so it's like that's not sarcasm i'm just
legit saying something stupid that i
don't actually believe
but it's on twitter so i can explain
right now this is my favorite part about
all of this i learned this you know
because i'm like i'm watching how
wikipedia works and stuff
i'm watching how i can literally say
in the microphone i i believe universal
health healthcare is something to strive
for it's a challenge to get there but
i'm absolutely in favor of it
not like bernie sanders with abolishing
private health insurance
uh i think social programs are fantastic
and i was a beneficiary of social
programs that helped help me stave off
homelessness but i do think there's
corruption we should we should weed out
i can say as many left-wing policy
positions as possible i'm pro-choice
i'm actually in favor of diversity in
films and movies just not this woke
garbage like i'd actually love to see
more women and people of color as lead
roles in superhero films
and they will keep saying over and over
again it doesn't matter what tim poole
says
he's right wing okay well then i'll go
on twitter and get all the journalists
in the world to say i love biden
and then write whatever you want but the
official sources say tim pool loves joe
biden
and then i'll have all the videos in the
world on my channel where i'm like
biden's trash
so i think it'll be it's it's an
interesting and you know you know what i
realized
let me explain too i don't care about
what these journalists say about me
i mean there was a period maybe where i
was like i was worried that they were
going to try and cause damage to my
person my business my property
and now i'm just like i really don't
part of it's because when you have the
microphone and a tv show of your own it
doesn't really matter what other people
say because people come to you directly
for the source so you can
always talk about that's how rogan's
navigated it throughout the years he's
just like come on guys well
i'll clarify too like deliberate
attempts to destroy my business and to
fame and slander and
and those things absolutely i will
reject resist and if i have to file
court cases right
i'm just saying like when they say
insane things about me like that are
opinions
tim poole is right wing and you know
whatever and we don't like him and he's
an idiot i'm like okay i don't care if
you insult me i don't care if you if you
don't like my opinions
you can you can say nasty things about
me fine whatever but
i can break the system you know what i
mean i guess you just have to not care
about twitter and i just really don't
yeah not take it too seriously
internet in general and like the way
people feel about you is really
you know as long as you have access to
communicate with people
that's the key if they i think when
you're when your rights are threatening
you're threatened with prison and like
being
removed from society that's very
dangerous but as long as
you're a free citizen like i i used to
tweet my work
i used to tweet links to v2 videos i
used to be a like yours my latest video
and i realized it didn't do anything for
me it just resulted in haters
hating on me tweeting garbage i just
like why am i bothering with this
website
i could put out a tweet it's it's it's
the meme of twitter i could put out a
tweet where i'm like
having a great what did i twist like i
want to get chickens and people like
you're so dumb
you're you're an idiot chickens are
stupid you're stupid and i'm like
what's the point of telling people i
want chickens what is the upside to
being like we're building chicken city
on this show we get critical comments
but most people are like
we're enjoying the content tim enjoy
watching your show twitter is a place
where you can go and yell at somebody
so i'm like all right let's have fun
with it let's just go nuts journalists
take this stuff seriously and they don't
do fact checking or research
all right i'll start saying a bunch of
weird stuff and just see i i got to be
honest
i didn't realize it was going to happen
in like three days
you know what i mean yeah three days tim
pool calls for impeaching the queen
that's right well firstly i i agree with
you i think that would be cool if the
british parliament rewrote their
constitution and they don't have one
peace their queen don't they have a
parliamentary constitution oh
they should write one no they don't have
a written take a cue guys
so what happened hey can we talk about
that story for a minute what happened
uh prince harry and his wife megan
called out the queen for being racist
fake news no royal family garbage
yeah we we fought a war to not have to
care about she's like 90 though isn't
she
she's abdicating or something okay let
me let me let me let me segue this into
something i think is uh much better
uh i i sang the um royal garbage is that
what you called it
what royal garbage yeah it's true
so uh decided to do another cleanup in
the uk
right seriously comes to parliament
comes to buckingham palace
um the media industry is collapsing it's
called the trump slump
so i i saw these stories and in line
with me just like not really caring i
just tweeted the lines to that song
i don't want to set the world on fire i
think it's called that oh yeah don't
want to say
from fallout i just want to start
a flame in your heart and it's an image
of huffington post laying people off
followed by the intercept saying since
trump left office our
our memberships and revenue has dropped
precipitously
cnn prime time ratings collapsing more
than 100 workers laid off from nbc
bloomberg lazy laying people's laying
people off mm-hmm
academic slam sinclair broadcast layoffs
then we have hallmark channel which is
not super news
and then news sites show early sign of
post-trump
slum this is it without donald trump
they will not exist i love how people
are like good song that's great and then
people are commenting you know
fallout whatever because the song's
right but these are just a small
sampling
of the trump slump without donald trump
to attack
and degrade they have nothing the the
best the best i i
i got to read this for you guys from the
intercept since donald trump left office
on january 20th
donations to the intercept have gone
down sharply after
years of steady growth last month
brought fewer newer members than we've
seen in more than two years
similar trends are being reported across
media and progressive politics
while trump railed against journalists
as the enemy of the people grassroots
outrage over trump's corruption racism
and incompetence
fueled a spike in ratings subscriptions
and fundraising they became known in the
industry as the trump
bump well i can say this
my respect to the intercept for
admitting they were just monetizing
people's anger at donald trump
and that now that he has gone they're
desperate and aren't making any money
they drove out glenn greenwald because
glenn greenwald was critical of the
democrats and joe biden
so he ended up having to resign from his
own outlet now who wants to give any
money but i'll tell you what the crazy
thing is
you got matt tybee glenn greenwald matt
tybee formerly of rolling stone glenn
greenwald
founder formerly of the intercept they
started something called a sub stack
were they right now on their own with no
you know boss telling what they can or
can't say
and people pay directly i am a proud
paying subscriber to both glenn and matt
because i think they do amazing jobs
i've been critical of glenn greenwald in
the past i do not think he's perfect
but i respect him for being for for
being consistent
for talking about what he believes for
writing these stories and it was a
tremendous sign of integrity when he
walked from the intercept his own
company
because they were trying to suppress
negative information on the buttons
well the trump slump is here any of you
surprised
not at all i think this is the democrat
party on full display right
you want to keep a problem around
without
actually solving it so you can point at
the problem and say hey we need more
money or more of this in order to solve
this but they never do
and now that president trump is gone
well
the trump slump is here oh man it's
hilarious i said
you know like a month before the
election the best thing for democrats
would be
if trump wins because the establishment
right now has tacit support from the
progressives because they all hate trump
that's the only thing unifying them
and the media will cease to exist
without donald trump
i mean that figuratively their ratings
will collapse and there will be a
bloodbath there will be layoffs
there will be business you know
newsrooms will close down
and it's happening it was like people a
lot of people probably wanted trump out
of office so they could go back to sleep
consciously regular people yeah i think
with the media
it's the it's the goose that laid the
golden egg donald trump was
laying golden eggs on twitter every day
daily daily hourly yeah sometimes too
much
but the media was able to use all of it
the obsession with trump it's a
it's an amazing thing i'd love to get an
objective
like academic review from a legitimate
academic on like the trump psychological
effects on people why everyone was so
obsessed with knowing what he was doing
or thinking
even even like look he's a celebrity
right the apprentice people just
love the idea of donald trump what did
barack obama say
the american dream is to be trump he
said that like the 90s or whatever
donald trump was the
guy the symbol of american success the
golden toilet he has
in his condo up in trump tower there was
an obsession with him
and when he ran for office and he and
and even before he won
the the people who hate him just they
loved to hate him
yeah he was like a hard worker very
physic like
fiscally successful you know came from a
hard family his dad was also a very hard
worker since he was 14
um but he was a jerk and like a mean not
not i don't know
no his dad was apparently and so was
donald he had a lot of those
like dislikable angry he'd get angry
whatever yeah i've not heard that i
haven't heard a lot i don't know him so
it's hard to say but
he didn't say stuff that was very crass
and rude and
so it was the dichotomy of a very
successful businessman that
really like the american dream but also
like a a crude dude
in his campaigns right and in his
private conversations that get released
you hear trump as a rude and crude dude
and a rude crude loot dude
but uh i went to i went to trump tower
um
you know during the campaign and i went
to is an ice cream shop there in new
york and they have the steak house
and i just asked people like hey have
you ever seen trump down here the
employees say yeah of course and i was
like what do you think he's awesome
yeah and they would tell me stories
about how he would come down with a
stack of 100 bills and just hand them
out to everybody
just here's a personal gift for me to
you don't worry about it it's tax free
gift 100 bucks
do whatever you want there's even a
video after he left office recently in
the past couple weeks
where he like walks up to some lady and
he hands her a 50 bill and he like
smiles and she's like oh my
thank you wow the stories i've heard
about donald trump in private are always
that he's a really calm and nice guy
that's about it the people who work
there seemed to enjoy working for him
they said he was great
they loved it when he was around because
it meant he was going to come and hook
him up and take care of him
but then when it came to the when it
came to the presidency he
looked trump did say a lot of things
that really aggravated a lot of people
he said a lot of things that i wasn't a
big fan of seemed
i didn't you know maybe maybe trump was
always like that would you know he
tweeted a lot about obama
and birtherism and stuff like that not a
fan of any of that so i definitely think
he's a rude crude lewd dude
but when people saw him in person he
seemed to have been genuinely super
charismatic
yeah easy to like also easy to hate it
was kind of depending on
what he felt like doing for the day you
know i think it's more so if you're mean
to him
he gets really angry and then he's
vengeful probably very vengeful
vindictive i don't know about vengeful
so i i heard that he
actually paid somebody's medical bills
do you guys know if that's true
i mean probably i would i wouldn't be
supposed to there's like a big story
super generous guy
yeah well look it's easy to be generous
when you're rich i don't care if it's
trump or oprah but yeah
it's true he's born into it too born
into just a million multi-million dollar
industry
yeah so but he did work to continue it i
think i don't know do you know much
about his
his fiscal life did he just kind of
maintain the business or did he grow he
grew too much
his own business he got a loan from his
dad he started his own real estate
company and it was bigger and more
successful than his dad's company nice
and uh the the haters it's just i don't
think it's easy to be generous when
you're rich
i think you're generous but it's not
right being generous is is
not everyone is it's it's like oprah
gave gives away cars and stuff and
everyone's like wow it's so nice
no no no it's the companies pay for it
the companies are like oprah will you
give away our cars so that we can get
more people to drive these cars
yeah it's an ad camp there's lots of
rich people that don't do that though
sure
sure sure the thing about trump that i
don't like is you know like dude
don't make me say something that's not
true i can't stand that so when they
were like trump's a failed businessman
he bankrupted a casino and i'm like
all of these casinos went bankrupt it
was it wasn't just trump's
trump casino and he had like what 500
businesses and five bankruptcies or
something like that i don't know listen
bankruptcy isn't failure no bankruptcy
means that you don't got to pay back
your debtors and you get to keep your
bill
your but your business it's a protection
lots of people are encouraged to do it
if they have too much credit card debt
right you're better off
declaring bankruptcy and then paying
waiting after seven years getting off
your credit record
but it's not even that it's the idea
like if you have a business and you have
more liabilities than revenue
and your business will fail if you lose
access to certain things you declare
bankruptcy
you get protected and your business
operates to try and recover so it's like
dude to claim that donald trump was
stupid or a bad businessman i'm like
just
stop lying does it make you feel better
to say he's worse
he is he is a a billionaire president
who married this model like come on man
many models and he had a huge hit tv
show like
literally the american dream became
president there's a lot of things to
insult the man for there's a lot of
things to criticize him for but i just
can't stand
the lies i just i just that's what i
hate about the whole thing
and the lies were so intense it was just
an endless spree of like let me defend
trump again i guess
because they just want you to live in
this fake reality where the orange man
is the villain
yeah there's a lot of things wrong with
trump but they just really really love
to hate them i wonder if they're going
to villainize biden
with this me too stuff if they're like
using this on cuomo they're going to
wait a little while
see if biden screws it up and then hit
him and put kamal into office
you think so scott they'll only do it to
throw him under the bus when they no
longer need him
and yes they i mean look at what they're
doing at cuomo yeah but everybody loves
a good villain look at the end of the
day
good heartwarming wonderful stories
don't sell
true you know look at the way the
republican party you know
treats aoc she's the pariah and now
look at the way the left is responding
to people like marjorie taylor greene to
madison cawthorne to
uh lauren beaubert i believe this is how
you pronounce her name
out of colorado those are the new aocs
of the right that they are demonizing
and that they are villainizing
and that's because it sells it's a click
it's a media hit and
it's unfortunate that those are the
people that they target and set their
sights on who's cawthorne
he's uh the the young gentleman out of
north carolina who just became a
congressman i think he's the youngest
congressman in history
25 years old that's like the minimum age
isn't it yes
yeah yeah he was actually 24 when he was
running
and he turned 25 subsequently after
being
elected wow and uh and yes is the
youngest congressperson good for him he
did tweet when he won
crime more libs and i was like nah nah
dude no
none of that you know but he's a young
guy so you know whatever man
uh we'll we'll see what he ends up doing
and if he if he acts a fool
and you know then i'll criticize them
the same as i would for anybody else
but uh i did i really do try to find
stories where i can be like i like
rashida taleb and aoc for these things
because i don't like that like i only
ever see the worst in them you know what
i mean
that's why it's like i try to say can
you name a good democrat can we like can
we find these people and give them
credit when where credit is due
it's difficult i'll give credit what aoc
did in texas
i mean look anybody can say oh she
should be focusing on her district she
should be focusing on new york look
it's an objectively good thing
that she raised and helped raise
millions of dollars for the people of
texas
that is objectively good and
nobody can say otherwise and quite
frankly where were republicans on the
right doing the same thing now i did see
some people who are out
um organizing food
and delivering food and doing things
like that but where were people on the
right
getting millions of dollars like the
left did yeah
well it was an opportunity for aoc and
i'll say this there's a lot of people
who are like she's just trying to
exploit situation for political gain and
my response is like oh no
like aoc is helping people in texas
it's like you cleaning up dare her yeah
right oh jeez you know what if she earns
political points because she helped
people in a crisis she deserves them
same for you scott if you if you earn
points because you got a bunch of clean
up
trash you deserve them so it's like by
all means from your place
and it just makes us look petty right if
we attack someone for doing something
good
let's real quick let's let's make the
political battle about who can do the
most good
yes let's be like aoc how she she's
she's winning the fight and helping
people who are in poverty ted you've got
to go in there and raise more money and
help more people
sure just for the record did you clean
up the trash to score
to get political clout the people what
was yours i did it because nobody else
was doing it
and i thought wow i have a
responsibility with this platform see
people don't understand
i actually feel a heavy weight on my
shoulders and because i've been gifted
with this large social media platform
that's the reason why i work non-stop
and why i actually feel guilty taking
days off because i feel like number one
who else is gonna do it and and i
challenge you at home please do it i
want you to do what i do i don't
i don't want all of this on my shoulders
and that's why i consistently work and
i'm
going towards 2022 because i feel like i
have this
moral responsibility to use my platform
for good
what about hold on i want it to be about
political points
i absolutely do i want everyone out
there to know that you
will make your political faction look
good when you go clean up your city
clean up trash
raise money to help poor people raise
money to feed feed those that are hungry
and provide shelter to the homeless
i want each and every person aoc i
believe deserves tremendous respect for
all of everything that she did in
helping these people and raising this
money i agree and now i challenge
republicans to
high-five her and say we're going to win
the competition next time because we're
going to help even more people than you
helped
and i want that to be politics imagine
ted cruz comes out
and he's like in my campaign i raised
five million dollars for
for this you know people aoc only raised
three million it's good that she did it
but we
won in helping more people vote for me
and we'll help people i'm like that's
great
like let's do that instead of yelling at
you people and wanting to fight each
other
um i don't think we've gotten into like
what you've been up to the last
three or four months i think you said
you've changed trajectory a little bit
i have so very much like after the 2016
elections
uh you know hillary clinton had some
ideas of why she lost the election
but the democrats really smart right
what they did
is they changed the law legally
and they started ballot harvesting in
california
and because of that all of orange county
went blue right it wasn't
witchcraft it wasn't shenanigans
they changed the law legally and so
i'm arguing for election integrity
moving forward
that why don't we do the same we control
the state legislature in 23
states we have trifecta governments we
got the governorship we got the state
house we got the state senate
it's within our power to change the laws
legally
to provide for additional election
integrity to fortify the election right
and we control the state legislatures in
pennsylvania
michigan wisconsin would you look at
that
swing states why don't we do the same
and at least
force the governors who are democratic
to
veto that legislation which would have
political
leverage repercussions going to the 2022
elections and should we
elect republicans in those states then
let's fortify the elections going into
2024 into the presidential so basically
i'm just saying look you guys at home
you have the power but it's up to you if
you choose to harness that power
and if you are not talking to your
legislators
writing them emailing them calling them
then quite frankly
you don't really care do you organize
daily phone calls like
at 2 p.m call this number well i did
just
uh read donald trump jr's tweet where he
was alerting us about sf145 which is
legislation in wyoming
that's currently introduced at the
senate committee level
which would allow for primaries
that don't have a clear 50 plus one
winner
it would go to a runoff election
therefore
taking away power from the liz cheney's
so liz cheney wouldn't be able to squeak
out a victory with 13
of the vote or 25 of the vote it would
go to a runoff election
and so yes when she just win the run-off
though not necessarily not necessarily
and so i did send out an emergency email
to my contacts in wyoming
and look at what's happening in georgia
for example state senate pass
legislation
that would allow for voter id for
absentee voting
so if people care you need to call and
get involved especially with
subcommittees where bills go to die
and so two important websites that i'm
asking people to go to are legiscan.com
to find legislation that's being
introduced at the state level and also
ballotpedia.org
to find more information about districts
that you live in all right well uh that
being said scott thanks for hanging out
let's go to uh super chats and if you
haven't already go to timcast.com click
that shop button and you can get your
very own
diamond hands gorilla that's right
welcome to the tim cast shopping network
we have a new shirt where it's the i'm a
gorilla but he's wearing a suit
holding lots of cash and he's smoking
while wearing sunglasses
i don't know if the smoking thing is
like going to get us in trouble or
something i don't know maybe is it a
cigar
yeah i think it's fine if it's a cigar i
mean you just pop
you just puff i don't know what it is
he's smoking something
and uh he is a diamond hence the frozen
diamond diamond hands
is when you don't sell the stock so
because he knows not to sell
he's sitting there reaping the rewards
of his attendees because the stock went
through the roof that's what the diamond
hands gorilla is
to the moon that's right yes go to
timecast.com become a member let's read
super chats
if you haven't already also smash that
like button all right let's see we got
deplorable pirate captain gunbeard who
says
a video recommendation forgotten weapons
weapons as political protest august 2nd
2017 and em
ian mccollum would be an awesome guest
in the future
also with your shield or upon it my
fellow gorillas
and that's right we have that new shirt
all right let's see
the civic nationalist says in the 1930s
the soviets were considered the greater
threat in the nazis
boy were they wrong maybe we are looking
at one foe instead of a greater
looking at one foe instead of a greater
one god save the queen long live britain
the sun has not yet set there you go
gizmo says what are the chances he gets
a fair trial
why doesn't the guard run them off in
reference to the autonomous zone um
because these people have
i don't know for some reason political
authority i suppose antifa just gets
away with all this stuff all the time
i heard that a french guy or a guy with
the last name chauvin
contacted me he said that the name is
pronounced shovan uh-uh
allison c says it's chauvin not chauvin
what
and that new autonomous own has been
there since summer but our totally
non-biased local news has been hiding it
yeah well somebody just died because
they won't put an end to it i saw richie
tweet about it it had been there for a
while and i was like wow
they heard about this yeah i guess they
went and explored it oh it's not new i
suppose
interesting all right let's see parallel
knight says make chicken fallout city
with vault overseers ooh that's a good
idea
get them a vault that overseer desk
let's make a little fallout themed
chicken city
oh my gosh high tech like a solar panel
on the roof too much fun
all right all right we got to do this
one paddy says milo is now choosing to
live his life as a straight man
oh come on is that real interesting
anything's possible with milo yeah
that's true i've seen a lot of people
just say
it's obviously attention it's working
we're talking about it right
i don't know he's a he's a master troll
he is that yeah
mega troll i'm not sure which one you
would prefer here we go yeah ella says
alison sees chad is right that zone has
been there since
summer police are blocked from the area
multiple shootings have happened in the
area wow okay so there's been a
long autonomous zone just operating
well well you know that's why i don't
live in these places omg
jimmyboy says if someone robs a bank now
can they just call an autonomous zone
and make demands
yeah i suppose so good stuff suburbs are
better
uh you get more space you know what i
mean and the bigger issue with cities is
mostly about
your your freedoms especially when you
have conflict
i think the biggest issue is like when
you live in a city you can't play music
you can't play drums a big difference
between you is i grew up in a suburb you
grew up in a city
yep so i i was all i knew growing up i
didn't know that there was like packed
in
yelling and loud noises from you i never
hurt my neighbors you know
you know chicago is not necessarily like
manhattan or anything
so where i lived in the south side it
wasn't as crammed as say
downtown or manhattan it was amazing to
have a yard growing up we would play in
the yard and like play baseball
in our backyard big backyard you can't
play baseball right so i think the
suburbs are where it's
where did you grow up suburbs
do you like a big yard front yard
backyard in florida we did
yeah yeah it's nice school backyard
yes having access to that grass is like
really
yeah amazing we have yards in chicago
but they're tiny tiny tiny yards
were you in a house or in a apartment
yeah so it's all houses next to each
other
but these autonomous zones it wouldn't
happen
in a suburb or a rural town the only
reason why it's happening is because
it has the majority support of the
people that live there
and because it's a democratic city you
have the support of the politicians that
are there
and the police are forced
because of social justice and because of
the media
to go along with the will of the people
and the politicians so that's the only
reason why these autonomous zones are
happening in
seattle washington and minneapolis
minnesota
because of those things being in place
all right we got avenger x90 says hey
tim missed your birthday stream
yesterday but happy late birthday keep
it the good work bro
we need more people like you in the news
sector that's right everybody if you
didn't know yesterday was my birthday
so uh thank you very much you can uh
smash the like button as a birthday
present if you so desire
that's all he wants for his birthday
commander 232 says well scott i don't
know your opinion on armstrong from here
in
north dakota but i myself decided to run
against him as he does nothing but sit
quietly in the corner
wish you all the best your fan anthony
bergen ps time for
north dakota to regain its voice are you
familiar with armstrong and i don't know
armstrong i don't know that race
there are a lot of uh politicians who
just try and keep their head down and
say nothing and do nothing
so those are those people are in my
opinion just as bad
if you're not defending the rights of
your constituents and you're just kind
of hiding in the back and saying just
don't notice me
that's still bad just uh just cuz says
autonomous zone of texas and red states
if they can do it with no repercussions
so can we come to our autonomous zone
tim and bring your chickens
well we're building a chicken city the
chicken city will be an autonomous zone
we should put in a ton of we'll put a
tournament zone on it
no but the chickens are in charge
[Laughter]
no i'm more shaking my head out of like
wow
exhaustion yeah come on our chickens are
going to be great
all right here we go sean says i live in
the suburbs and work construction
doing jobs near floyd plaza is crazy
seeing businesses boarded up and shut
down with blm signs everywhere is wild
i have to drive 10 minutes to use the
bathroom whoa this is the scariest thing
about what's happening
is that in like berkeley people put the
signs in their window
and and some of them even say please
don't hurt us when michael tracy
traveled on the country after the blm
riots
tons of businesses had signs saying
things like please
please we're a minority owned business
don't hurt us please don't hurt our
family
oh no i have a theory i think some of
these businesses
don't agree with blm but they
simply are putting those up in their
window for that sole purpose
that they won't be attacked they won't
be burned to the ground well they have
to live under a boot
dude the last time i i i heard of people
putting things up in their window was
the euden
in the nazi germany where they would
make people put a star of david on their
door
jewish that's different that was
different but did they also put the
swastika on their door if they supported
the party
what's happening now is that people are
scared antifa will burn down their
businesses or or black lives matter
writers will
so they put messages of support on the
property hoping it will protect them
it'll work for a small business but it
won't refer corporation like whole foods
did it and they smashed at whole foods
anyway
but the smaller businesses it's a sign
of like
fealty essentially you're you're you're
you're bending the knee as a coward
begging uh these these these violent in
psychopaths
you know begging them please i'm so weak
and pathetic that if i just agree with
whatever you say you'll leave me alone
and they eventually just come
and take everything and burn down anyway
so they think they'll the
these people these people who think
putting the sign in their window and
then
dropping to their knees and keeping
their head down will keep them safe are
just wrong
they've not learned from history steven
voiceover says did you guys
see jeremy's video today about the girl
that was driven to delete her channel
if lids could look her up maybe you guys
could give her a shout out you guys rock
keep doing what you're doing
oh and tim keep doing the impressions
yeah which ones
oh bernie sanders yes oh yeah it's too
good
bernie sanders was i i was doing that
one downstairs was that doing it on the
show now mm-hmm sometimes
you did earlier i didn't even notice you
were doing it i invoke the spirit of
it the millionaires and the billionaires
no no no no he doesn't say millionaires
anymore
since he became a millionaire have you
noticed the transition
he only talks about the billionaires a
couple weeks ago he mentioned
millionaires i think he's been watching
your videos
he's watching he's like no he's right no
he was like
i'm a big fan i can't believe i offended
him you're right
some millionaires the joke i made before
was that like we have a door downstairs
and i said
you have this ivory tower that the left
and the right populists are trying to
break in two to get to the establishment
political positions
and trump was just like a bull slamming
into the door and bernie was politely
knocking
well they opened the door for bernie and
then bernie's got all these left
populists behind him and he goes
thank you for letting me in just just
one minute he turns around and then he's
closing the door behind him just just
wait right here i'll be back and then he
closes the door and just joins the
establishment
they still like him though because he's
leaning out the window saying don't
worry i'm fighting for you trust me
and then he goes back in and they all
laugh and they give him you know whiskey
but actually trump is going crazy so all
right thomas david says
where's luke what up ian luke went to an
article a narco polco i think yeah yeah
i saw a video on his instagram yeah he
was a speaker i think wasn't he cool
yeah yeah yeah good for him all right
what is this lucy lurker says for the
love of all things holy please hang the
picture up
that is on the floor behind the guest
chair i love you guys happy belated b
day
well we we have there's a couple
actually on the ground
and i do like the one on the ground we
need more picture wire that's why we
didn't hang it up yeah because the other
ones are
are hung properly so but i do like the
biden eating the little girl more than
the
the rogue one you too we need we need to
update it too because the trump
biden debate one i think is a little
dated this temporary one yeah yeah now
the biden eating the child i think is is
more relevant and then we'll have two
two pictures because behind ian
we also have the uh okay boomer girl
getting eaten by biden i want to get joe
on the show
while we still have the picture of joe
behind him yeah
joe rogan yeah i hope
yeah yeah yeah let me let me just tell
joe yeah very busy man
do it morgan h said remember bill maher
said in the air that he'd be willing to
see the u.s economy crash if it meant
getting trump
out of office yes we all knew it let all
the american people suffer
good stuff yeah all right let's see what
we got
rex the sauce lord says it's okay tim
don't lose hope for my generation i've
grown up here in san diego
i'll be 22 next month and me and my
friends all understand what hard work
is and we're trying to make something
for ourselves we all voted trump by the
way awesome very interesting
weld girl says u.s law shield legal
defense for self-defense and gun law by
state resource for two-way discussions
love the beanie brigade hey you
appreciate it
all right let's see where are we at race
gardener says yeah jimmy dore covered it
the day trump tweeted 2k
checks then dems like pelosi and schumer
started to say 2k checks wow
yeah that's interesting i think wow
jimmy dore covered it
they don't like jimmy the the
establishment does not like jimmy
all right let's see shauna ray says
first super chat love you guys
thanks for all you do it's frustrating
to live in florida and see all of my
left friends constantly bashing desantis
they don't know how good they have it in
florida i mean unless they're uh
like authoritarians who are mad that
he's allowing republicans a voice and
you know what i mean
yeah some people are really afraid of
code all right see adam says
crowder did a whole protest in michigan
a hold protest in michigan about whitmer
killing the elderly and not releasing
nursing home deaths she blocked freedom
of info act requests for the actual
death numbers from nursing home several
times
also she blocked a bipartisan bill to
stop her from forcing young coveted
positive patients into nursing homes
all of this info is in one of one of his
videos from a few days ago love you all
love you too
and now i think charlie leduff he's a
detroit
reporter he filed his lawsuit didn't he
i think so i think he's finally
following a lawsuit against whitmer over
the numbers that they want they want to
be really busy
too mitch stu says
gamestop will be 500 a share by friday
gamestop is only beginning research
naked shorts which is the illegal
activity of predatory hedgies
it is the modern day wolf of wall street
i am using my gains to buy my first home
wow congratulations see
diamond hands these people who knew not
to sell now i'm not giving any financial
advice i don't know what's gonna happen
gamestop
i can tell you that we have made an
exclusive diamond hands gorilla t-shirt
over at timcast.com
and then click that shop button and you
will see it and it is a suit wearing
gorilla so that's great
bernstein wolfe says tim happy belated
birthday you're an inspiring dude
i'm an la based fine artist rebuilding
after 2020 i'd be honored to draw you a
portrait as a b
day gift or anyone on the beanie crew
for that matter
see my work at
boosted says tim have you heard of the
great barrington declaration it's a
petition signed by thousands of medical
and public health scientists speaking
out against lockdowns
young ripa did a video on it and youtube
deleted it right away
yikes yeah well i'm not surprised
it is a fine line and uh it's
interesting sometimes why some channels
get taken down and others don't whatever
seth has says yo tim go to google's
homepage and there is a link to google
trends with the hashtag
stop asianhate this has to be a play by
the ccp
supposedly there's an uptick in racism
towards asian since covered no that's
true there is
there is there there absolutely has been
a lot of attacks on asians
there's videos of it man i mean stuff
happens you know what i mean like
racism is bad racism happens the problem
i have with it was when
you have a bunch of lefties go out and
protest white nationalism when the
people
who are in this specific case the guy
who attacked the asian guy was a black
dude
i don't think race matters i think stop
attacking people based on race
instead the left these leftist activists
have found a way
to turn an issue of ending racism into
legit being racist i guess and not
caring about what actually is going on
in this country
it is what it is man x says nuclear
power is technically not renewable
it's just basically endlessly
sustainable and environmentally friendly
especially after fusion
well that would be great yeah and
endless isn't quite accurate but because
it
goes for so long it seems endless in the
short term
okay so denman says fukushima was an
aged out reactor that didn't have
passive cooling
modern reactors are designed to cool
without needing to be running
interesting
jim jam says the elites think that they
could that if they can get to you
wait wait the elites think that if they
can get you to do
without it it offsets their footprint
and they are good
look at bill gates interview about his
book he says so plain as day
it's very simple forever you know like
think about how many carbon emissions
are made by a private jet
how many people have to not fly in order
for you to keep using your private jet
that's the plan yeah that's it yeah
right
eco sophist says tim and ian fusion tech
is 20 years away
and always will be yeah see if john
michael greer will come to the studio
they always say that it's like john
michael greer
uh john michael greer yeah maybe that's
the key
yeah gizmo says can you prove climate
change is man-made and not just the
cyclical nature change
uh cyclical nature change of climate ice
age the climate of dinosaurs even 200
years ago
the climate constantly changes without
man
i'm not going to assume is a grand
conspiracy of all of these different
countries and everything
you know when you look at the carbon
emissions in the atmosphere there's a
major spike
and i think it's fair to say that will
contribute in some capacity but all i
can really do
is trust uh what we view as modern
science to a certain degree
not blindly i don't blindly trust
anything but
what am i supposed to do what's the
average person supposed to do i think it
is a natural cycle and humans are part
of the natural cycle our technology
although it seems metallic and
electric and synthetic is part of the
natural cycle but like volcanoes
and cometary impacts cause massive
amounts of
uh global warming if you look at the
firestorm 12
800 years ago that melted the ice caps
like
so it's it's definitely cyclical if you
look at the the nature of ice ages it's
cyclical it goes up and down and up and
down and
so seems like it i don't know man i'm
not a climatologist
and i usually only defer to experts so
that's why
the show's fairly milk toast i guess
because i don't come out and say
i know better than academic literature
for the most part
that tends to be the case and a lot of
people don't like it especially on the
left when they try and claim
things like biological sex doesn't exist
i'm like i'm sorry dude i just
like the academic literature says one
thing and i'm not the scientist so i'm
just going to go by
they try and make all these you know
it's it's sophistry often when they make
their arguments
you need to do better and just go around
telling people how dare you
yes yeah china's allowed to have call
power plants bro
you're not that's so weird kl mckee says
gates has purchased a large portion of
railway in canada
if the pipe gets laid less money for the
gates also mr pressler
it might feel like you're on a talk show
but you're the new news
excellent i'll take that i think so
kenny jackson says elysium industries
molten salt fast reactor literally eats
spent nuclear fuel to create power look
it up please it's fascinating that's
amazing
jav tanda says chernobyl fukushima and
three mile island sound like a few small
examples
but the issue is that the damage nuclear
leaks caused and continue to cause is
disproportionate when compared to oil
spills
disproportionate in terms of like not
that much how many people have died from
nuclear
disasters it's it's tough to it's tough
to measure because the corium
is radioactive so when it melts and
melts through the ground of the nuclear
plant into the earth and sits there and
radiates the earth
or into the ocean which is where all
that fukushima stuff went
radiates the plants and the fish it
could cause long
lasting impacts and it's tough to get
rid of the corium because it's in a
constant state of meltdown
all right let's see johnny silverhand
says i'm a millwright apprentice about
to graduate from trade school
i applied at a place called snow lab
that's doing experiments with nuclear
power
and got an interview hope i get the job
it'd be awesome to be a part of that and
a little uh atomic symbol
that's cool a stink bug got scott
i got stinkbug bass player says hey tim
make sure your car seat belts work and
you aren't being followed by the
paparazzi also don't drive through
tunnels with no cameras hey
strong advice puffy says timothy daniel
poole calls to impeach queen elizabeth
again on his show new york times
man allergies coming back it's canon
brandon tom says talking about your
anti-tweeting do you see the parallels
between your tweeting garbled nonsense
of left talking points and the grievance
studies happy belated birthday yeah
uh yeah yeah for the most part let's
talk about the grievance studies
yeah i believe we will eric miller says
tim here's your argument if nuclear is
so bad
why do we have all these nuclear
submarines contaminating our oceans
slogan let's be clear on nuclear
green nuclear they tried doing clean
coal on the left-hand like it
broverly bra says this time on timcast
tim discovers the power of twitter-ish
posts
uh we don't swear on the show so it
means true though
hey here we go youtube says youtube
comments
look up montana freeman a right-wing
autonomous zone in montana in 1996
it didn't end well for them can we just
call the antivir people sovereign
citizens
sure in the autonomous zones i'm gonna
start referring to them as sovereign
citizens
because they you know they are they're
people who are claiming they're
autonomous what's the difference same
thing
snowboard dan says temple aka the living
meme master
yeah i just think i just really don't
care about this stupid garbage anymore
that's how you make a meme apc doc says
i'm with scott america first candidates
only for 2022 and beyond
how would you define an america first
candidate
the philosophy of every piece of
legislation
and every bill that you vote on should
be
under the question does this benefit the
american people
or does it not quite simply so i mean
if you have the ability to have a budget
bill
and money is going to iran
money is going to honduras guatemala the
rest of the world and
we're not spending that money on
infrastructure i'd say
down vote don't vote for the budget bill
that's aiding
the rest of the world and not america
does it secure the border does it make
sure we're putting the american people
first does it make sure that
uh you know it just has to come back to
america first
there's this christian philosophy from
jesus one of the things he said is take
the
the point we talked about this last
night take the plank out of your own eye
before you try and take the mode of dust
out of your friends yeah all right
josh codes irl says scott thanks so much
for sending me info after the league
city event
you inspired me to get involved and
start wearing conservative gear while
doing neighborhood cleanups and trying
to register voters
oh i'm so happy there you go i'm so
thrilled
situation normal says lmao check wiki
tim poole
quote views and then a googly face yup
yup yup it's hilarious
it's like figure that one out i guess
all right let's see charlie and charge
says it makes total sense that joe biden
is president
and all these major cities keep voting
blue and support these writers
people are only are the only species on
the planet that gets dumber in large
numbers
i think a lot of animals get dumb in
large numbers but uh
it's an issue of manipulation i i think
taking advantage of someone makes you
the bad guy not the person who who's
being taken advantage of
and i feel bad for these people i agree
but at a certain point the people who
know what they're doing
they're the bad guys you know all right
let's see
if sd says love you scott would love it
would love if you could give a birthday
shout to my friend carrie
hi carrie this is scott pressler i just
wanted to say happy birthday to you this
is your official shout out on
tim cast oh yeah right on
james dineen says tim are you going to
start a video game and technology
technology
channel as part of the beanie news
network love the show gorillas grow
together um yes i don't know when we've
talked about it quite a bit
we actually are working on a video game
we actually have a
video game in development right now so
i've long talked about we're making a
video game
and uh ian's working on a card game and
the video game yeah
and a video game extremely fun and
they're going to be amazing we've
already talked about it
who's involved with it right i don't
know how specific we've been involved
yeah we talked a little bit about the
card game
we've mentioned champions working on
sheamus is doing the art so it's freedom
tunes art
for the video game too right it's yeah
for the video game too it's gonna be
incredible i mean i've been i've been
working on um
level design and development of the
video game for the last like two or
three weeks it's just so exciting
watching the advancements
in it it's a i guess a procedurally
general
procedurally generated roguelike game
you know so there's gonna be it's gonna
be funny
uh i don't know how much we should say
just yet but you know the game's getting
there
and it's going to be a whole lot of fun
it's going to be one of the best games
ever made and as for technology i'm
totally into doing like server builds
and computer builds and all these
we have some amazing technologists in
house that i think we could really
utilize
grayson dennis says tim cast irl
my disappointment is immeasurable and my
day is ruined
just saw the diamond hands gorilla
t-shirt and i can't believe you didn't
give him actual diamond hands
i'd buy that shirt i thought that was
too on the nose no it's great
to give him actual diamond hands would
just be over the top we'll have to make
like a superhero like the evolution of
the gorilla into like a superhero with
diamond skin we are working on the love
yourself one the problem is like we've
gone through a couple different designs
and it's like
how do you make it about love loving
yourself it's just a gorilla going yeah
i'm a gorilla and so we're trying like a
thumbs up and a wink
you have two gorillas sitting on a on a
ledge above a pond
like just hanging out love yourself you
know communication
yeah you know he didn't like that idea
eric cheese says
fun fact uranium glass grows green under
uv light
that's likely where the idea of glowing
green at nuclear waste came from
interesting yeah remember that guy who
built the
nuclear reactor in his garage or
whatever and he raided his his like
house gosh he's like i forgot what he
did but he took um
uh how do you pronounce it americium you
know what i mean americium or something
it's in smoke detectors and then he put
massive amounts and he put it in like
this bucket or something and drilled a
hole in it so it
was blasting neutrons or something and
he was covered in lesions
oh my god right now that's a bad lad
yeah
away from you thanks god ryan
berka berkabol says put the gorilla in
boxing gloves i beat godzilla
oh that's cool yeah michael grant says i
made a video a while ago about nuclear
power called nuclear power the only way
forward
the main problem is that people don't
know that the radiation that sticks
around
isn't harmful that's what's that's the
thing it's the corium that's dangerous
not the radiation itself once it's once
the
the piece of corium that's radiating is
taken away there's no long there's no
leftover
danger for the most part that i can tell
it seems like
so you just gotta somehow um recover the
spent fuel
let's just do a couple more we have uh
monk
mighty 420 says sovereign citizen is an
oxymoron you can't be both a sovereign
and a citizen
happy belated birthday appreciate it and
then we have jalapeno ketchup says love
scott
heart there you go we'll do one more
ryan says go listen to band
banned made they will change your life i
will consider it and we'll uh
here we go we'll do one more we'll do
one more grim soul banisher says hey tim
and crew i would love to write articles
and reviews for your websites about film
and games
i don't want to be paid i just want to
contribute would you be willing to
publish happy late b day
uh we will be doing um contributors
on the site absolutely it will always be
paid so
uh you know i don't i don't like having
people work and then not get something
for it so it'll always be paid
but uh we'll when we get to that point
the website is uh
getting close there will be a like you
know blog function where people can
write articles and stuff like that and
uh
we're getting there so we'll we'll see
how things play out but uh everybody
thanks for hanging out if you haven't
already smash
that like button we will have the
members only exclusive segment coming up
in about an hour over at timcast.com
also go to timcast.com click shop get
that
diamond hands gorilla t-shirt if you
haven't already
this one will probably stick around i
don't think this one will be a limited
this one might be limited edition
because we might take it out at some
point because gamestop is only
like in the new cycle for for a certain
amount of time we do have a couple
limited
limited edition gorilla shirts that are
going to be coming up and other art too
because not just gonna be an endless
stream of gorilla t-shirts but uh
anyway we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm leave us a good
review if you're listening on itunes or
spotify or whatever give us all those
stars
and you can follow me on all podcasts on
all social media platforms
at tim cast my other channels are
youtube.comtymcastenyoutube.comtimcastnews
and scott is anything you want to
mention before we uh dip out
you can follow me uh tdot me scott
pressler that's my telegram
and just now liz cheney adam kinzinger
lisa murkowski we are peacefully and
democratically
coming to take your seats in 2022. right
on
yeah i want to hear more about that next
time maybe um
hey guys i want to give a couple shout
outs ian crossland.net is my website
where you can go and check out all my
social media accounts there
look at the merchandise store if you
like things like this cool mug that i
drink out of this is free the code
and also to luke grakowski who is in an
archipoca
yeah we are change.org this is one of
his shirts you can get on his website
uh thebestpoliticalt-shirts.com i
believe it is you go to we are
changing.org
thank you so much for coming oh yeah and
me i'm sitting in the corner pushing
buttons i forget to push button to
myself
i'm sour patch lids on twitter and mines
and i'm real sourpatch lids on instagram
where you can join me for my post show
tea chats they're very short
and i am also on gib we will see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out
and uh we'll see you there bye guys
you